[Music]
we are now entering the Great Hall of
the liver King animals fall before him
they cower in fear
that's the liver King baby
he's here
with Hassan of course this is kind of a
dream come true for us absolutely we
bonded over our admiration for you a
long time ago yeah I know yeah 100
to have the liver King I Can Smell You
by the way I know you don't wear
deodorant right melted tar right oh not
that bad melted tar oh that's good I
smell like a man oh right that's what I
say I'm like hey that's what a bee
smells like it smells like melted tar
mahogany Hamlet you know because people
want to say it smells horrible I'm like
I'm gonna give you some better
adjectives what are the most masculine
adjectives I can come up with in like
that that's about so if you got better
adjectives you give it to me but please
listen it it doesn't smell bad it just
smells like like you know Bo but that's
fine that's how you do it those are the
pheromones right that's right that's
right but I appreciate you guys have me
on because you probably hear this all
the time you say hey thanks for coming
on and the guest says hey thanks for
having me right and so this is what I
like to do in the beginning of podcasts
I want to really put towards what I what
I mean by when I say thank you and and
I'm so grateful because I desperately
need badass primals and sometimes alike
right to have these kind of animals
right because now look at him when he's
yeah and that's okay am I the sub Primal
and that's fine because I'm fast why do
you think you're so Primal I didn't say
that well I'm not I'm saying this
categorically okay you looked at him and
you said Primal and sub Primal as well
I'm not in my Primal shape I'll get it I
got I got one of the smartest most
genius guys that works within the tip of
the spear this is the smartest guy you
ever meet
um he is definitely not Primal and then
people say things and then he takes
things completely out of context I think
you might be too smart for your own good
sometimes because I'll just tell you
right now all I'm saying is I'll go on
any show anywhere if you hate me if you
love me if you're Primal if you're
subprime if you have an audience then
then you have somebody I can speak to
right because I'm hurt in hate and
suffering struggle today that this is
indiscriminate right there's so many men
today that are aimlessly wondering about
life there's no purpose no passion
there's no fight there's no unite
there's weak and and there's submissive
men listen there's a whole world of
people today that are suffering with
depression anxiety and fertility you've
probably heard me talk about this right
there's low energy low libido and low
ambition in life there's a better life
to live and I know that you guys know
this because the way that you guys laugh
the Roar of your laughter right you
can't laugh like that and be expansive
and contract and have a life of scarcity
at the same time so you all know this
life and so that's what I'm championing
today is because of this kind of hurt
hate suffering struggle this is my job
right to advance these nine ancestral
tenants so that our people no longer
have to suffer so we can express our
highest most dominant without a show
like this I don't have a chance to reach
audiences so that's when when you say
hey man thanks for coming on like hey
thank you for having me that's it that's
the real yeah look at only a year listen
and I'll say this oh I know we've been
trying to get you all you had to do was
send me a jet put me up in a penthouse
yeah I know that's all you had to do
since you mentioned that let me just
show the people uh what we're referring
to uh liver King has been hyping this
visit up on Instagram stories first uh
it was that I'm gonna get canceled for
this I saw that I saw that Instagram
story I was like oh no people are gonna
yell at me well because they got
chartered a jet yeah people I guess
people don't like the private jet
because it's not Eco well it's not
eco-friendly uh Taylor Swift got
canceled for it she was but but liver
King doesn't give a [ __ ] about that no
what I give a [ __ ] about is the greater
good right if what it takes is a private
jet and a penthouse suite right so get
me over here just spread the message
millions of people
okay
you can't cancel liver bro yeah oh I
love them forever yeah
primals over at the H3 podcast it was H3
right yeah
such a huge fan huh liver this is the
deal hey I go where they tell me and
they're like hey H3 has has a giant jet
waiting for you right they already have
this sweet so that's not very so it's
Primal to be driving like it's still
Primal I just because I don't know I
wanna like driving Primal well I'm gonna
tell you it 100 is and I'm gonna go
ahead and put this to bed once and for
all because people say this [ __ ] forever
right hey driving in the car is not you
know is this Primal flying in a jet you
know having a beach house is up having a
ranches and so this is what I say like
The evolutionary hunter that left the
comfort of the cave they did this for a
better life right they left the comfort
of the cave to go explore adventure and
excitement and to pull our entire
ecosystem forward you had those other
guys remain in the shadow I call those
guys the subprimals making reaction
videos sitting on the couch right yeah
[ __ ] that yeah [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate those
guys man straight up but because this is
what happened I would never do the
evolutionary Hunter left and he started
to collect the skeletal remains because
we before we were apex predators we were
scavengers right the apex predators
would do their thing they would leave
the skeletal remains we would collect
the cranium we would collect the femur
bones we would bring that back we
figured out how to use percussion
technology to crack that open Jeffrey
Dahmer to well I don't know I bet is
that we're talking about this he has a
big uh Netflix documentary somebody was
talking about Jeffrey Dahmer yesterday
I'm like why is everybody
because Evan Peters killed it I mean
literally and figuratively he uh Jeffrey
Dahmer a new show on Netflix kind of
controversial people are upset about it
well I think oh yeah people were upset
because it's like dude it's
re-traumatizing no because it's too good
I think that's literally the reason I
just want to go eat a heart well Jeffrey
Dahmer like you eats Hearts well let me
say human hearts right well Hearts
Jeffrey Dahmer Primal or not Primal well
I I I I'm gonna say it I'm gonna make
this official right here's the thing
before I make it official I really want
to prove this point
um lyricing doesn't plug into trending
stuff so somebody brought this up
yesterday on a podcast I'm like why are
people talking about well I mean well
not exactly trending he did this in 1991
like that's what apparently but
apparently it's trading because there's
a new documentary recognition right but
but percussion technology came first and
then and then the guy that's sitting in
the comfort of the cave says hey that's
not very Primal you're using technology
right and then we figure out how to
sculpt that rock into bifacial blade and
the subpriminal says hey this is not
very Primal then we figure out fire at
will we figure out language these innate
Technologies and if you just look at
technology over time technology has a
story across time and space right and
then we built houses and planes and cars
and technology is a utility until it no
longer is so what I would say is is
driving in that F450 dually tank
evolutionarily because it's a 450. it's
an F450 dually tank you come on a
head-on collision with this guy and and
you will kill a whole [ __ ] family of
people if you need to hey whatever
whatever it takes to get the message out
is for the greater gun yeah let me ask
you this then by that logic because that
is interesting you talk about technology
as we evolve that is what's Primal right
we're coming out of the cave this is
utility a utility so what is your is
GMOs Primal so I say that it's a it's
technology and it's Primal it's
ancestral until it no longer is and
until it's toward detriment so I'm going
to give you an example with social media
right because people like hey you're on
social media oh that yeah you're a real
Primal I'm like okay you got me you got
me first and foremost my phone is on
airplane mode I don't know if you call
the phone at that point but I use it as
a camera right and I use social media as
this incredible weapon to get this
message out right I I follow nine people
total half of my family liver boys and
liver Queen right so I would say I use
social media to create and to curate
value once you use it to mindlessly
consume content and now that's a
placeholder for real value that you can
create with stacks and compounds inside
yourself that you can express to the
outside world once you use it to your
detriment I would say it no longer is
Primal so what about when you're on the
toilet though you don't want to like
look at tick tocks when you're pooping
no I mean why would you want to get that
thing you know what I I use my best
weapon right I think about [ __ ] yeah
well what do you think about this point
yeah you know what I don't even know
what I thought I probably I thought
about you guys yeah you know oh what an
honor Brian thinking about you guys but
going back to the GMO question I think
that was a good one so so so is GMO
Primal or subprime at this point that's
what I'm thinking when you start to get
into manipulate like Gene editing that
kind of stuff genetic modifications
right now I would say that falls that's
completely subprival right because you
could say the same thing I mean if
you're just editing a stick you're
taking a stick you're turning into a
spear you could say the same thing about
uh uh uh tomato he's so sorry he needs
you to tell him that frozen pizzas are
Primal that's not what I think if people
just splice the the genes of [ __ ]
tomatoes that they could live better in
the cold and therefore feed more people
or right and is that good and this is
one of the most dangerous things I'll
tell you why not because people think
living better like here's the thing you
know and I get this criticism all the
time yeah but our early ancestors live
till 30. and I'm like you call what
we're doing today living right because
we figured out how to prolong life it
would be very I I do think that this is
better I'm just gonna say it like it was
pretty [ __ ] up because like I don't
wanna yeah I don't want to die from like
you know dysentery or whatever like I
think it's pretty chill I get to look at
tick tocks or like people are straight
up dying of the flu like a [ __ ]
there's like
Instagram
these are these are the facts 85 of
people today live with self-esteem
issues eighty percent eighty percent
struggle paycheck to paycheck and you
got to figure out why like we're trying
to express our worth and potential in
the world with [ __ ] that we buy at the
mall say it whatever you want to call it
80 of people are struggling paycheck to
pay 70 are overweight half World beats
50 on prescription meds 40 however will
get cancer 20 experience infertility now
you can't look around this room and tell
me either you yourself someone in your
family or people around this room are
suffering with these things yeah you
think that's a better life
we're hurting at record rates no I I I
advocate for a better system across the
board so I'm fully on board with what
you're saying and I do think that
Fitness plays a good role in that as
well I think goal setting and like
achieving said goals is also a really
good way for me at least and uh to to
live my life that's how I've been able
to accomplish things that I have
accomplished
um but ultimately I do like the uh the
fun stuff like you know I I like uh I
like eating a pastry every now and then
you know
week you know what I don't have to say
anything you guys already know you guys
already know let me tell you this if you
go visit with these modern day primitive
culture tribes in the Amazon in Africa
we're headed to Mongolia in a couple of
weeks here's the thing you're going to
find that these primitive culture tribes
have absolutely no material possessions
have no access to pastries have no
access to videos no the kind of life
that they live I guarantee every single
person here would be envious of they're
more I know but they've never had an ace
in Valor at that's all I'm gonna say
Okay valerian's video game I don't know
when you get an ace in it like you feel
so calm for how long for for a while
actually
it doesn't fulfill me liver cancer
because hey props for you but but this
is what I believe sucking up to him I'm
telling him the truth I think you're
just gonna think especially it's on yeah
I made a video the other day we were
high lifting we were mudding out at the
ranch we were shooting guns and then
somebody said and I made this comment
you don't need video games when you can
lead real life like this with your
family without Warriors and [ __ ] and and
so somebody responded hey must be real
nice if you have millions of dollars and
I'm thinking really that's interesting
maybe you go get millions of dollars if
you stop doing video games and do real
life and did you ever beat a video game
and say oh my God I did it I got it
Jason Valor let hear me out and and then
you said this changed my life this is
part of my legacy and this is a lasting
dopaminergic thing that uplifts that's
so true liver yes uh he's wrong
there was a video yeah it's a it's made
by this man named Miyazaki from software
is the company they make these games
called Dark Souls yeah Elden ring oh
so this game actually unironically
taught me a lot about like controlling
my anger and frustration
um it's a single player game it's not
even like competitive you're just like
literally trying to defeat these bosses
and they're so difficult okay they're so
incredibly difficult to defeat and you
need to get the timing correct it's like
you need to get the Rhythm correct you
need to study their move sets every time
you do something there's like an
adequate reaction coming from that boss
so you need to like manipulate your own
movements to make sure that your enemy
is doing the wrong things all of that
stuff is so tilting and so frustrating
when you play on your own and you're
just getting angrier and angrier and
angrier but then at a certain moment you
realize like well if I keep bouldering
through at this problem I'm not going to
be able to accomplish it so actually
Elden ring and from software games have
genuinely changed my perspective on how
to uh to to control my frustration it
seems like it was a hunt of some sort
yeah
no I'm 31. you're 31 so like I would say
what are your roles and goals in life
right for me I'm like I'm a husband I'm
a boss I'm a brother right I have
certain rules and goals and I'm thinking
what role in Gold would that make me
better at and if one of your roles is
I'm an entrepreneur in video games is my
thing you know then good on you right
because that will make you better more
build more valuable to your outside
world right for me this is not one of my
roles and goals well I think I mean we
can all agree I play video games I mean
playing video games is subprime let's
just be real about it right yeah I'm
sorry liver smoking on the issue right
absolutely yeah that's like a no-brainer
I think I think playing video games is
fine as long as you do it in moderation
moderation let me actually I'm going to
put this to rest too my own liver boys
play video games who do they play okay
um there's like asphalt there's a racing
game oh yeah there's like a puzzle
solving game
um there's some first person no
Fortnight Fortnight that one that was
3.4 now so here's the thing so people
ask me all the time do you let you if
you believe this is subprimal do you let
your kids do subprimal things and this
is what I say if if you earn it you can
go do it okay right if you don't earn it
you're not you're not getting access
like that doing that okay so they get up
in the morning and they immediately
stack the sun in the earth they make
their own breakfast they get a workout
in their first workout of the day they
do two workouts every every day they do
Jiu Jitsu they do you striking they do
ninja practice and the kind of stuff
that they do their days are full and and
you know what now you get 40 minutes to
go do whatever the [ __ ] you want and if
you want to spend that playing video
games and then and trust me like we do
wins around the table hey man let's talk
about wins and then half the time the
wins are related to a video game and I'm
like okay and I tell them what I just
said to you do you think in your life
you're going to say oh I just crushed it
because I'm the best in this video game
right now this is important can I ask
you a question do you think maybe your
kids are having genuine experiences that
you just don't have access to because
you're kind of Boomer and I don't mean
that offense I'm a boomer too but I mean
just because it's not an experience that
you've shared and potentially maybe it's
you that's wrong
or at least not being empathetic enough
to their Human Experience so I'm open to
that but here's where I would push back
I grew up in the 80s so I was born in
the 70s I grew up in the 80s and I
played John but how old are you liver
King what the [ __ ] I'm 45. oh my god
dude oh he looks younger than both of
them
look at the skin man yeah oh [ __ ] I have
so many questions well we're gonna well
let's get into it okay but here's the
thing his sweat is glistening down bro
you look amazing are you hot right now
you know what that's the thing my
thermoregulatory mechanisms I don't wear
all the deodorant the [ __ ] that blocks
it so I'm like right now I'm perfect
this is my homeostasis this is my air
conditioning coming on we would play
John Madden but you know the graphics
were so horrific after 30 minutes and
you just watch your friend you could see
him what he was playing right and so
after 30 minutes you go out in the
street you play football right when you
put down the phone when you put down the
video game when you come in here you
create this kind of electricity you can
never ever tell me that video games are
going to Trump this kind of real life
let me push back more I I got addicted
to Halo oh okay I got addicted to one of
us that's crazy okay and uh and so I had
stopped playing video games um I started
I had to do this thesis in college and
so um I so I had to stop and then one of
my buddies said hey now there's a like
online thing that you can do well you're
a loser you're a loser and I played it
and I couldn't believe it so so good it
was so funny you play Halo multiplayer I
started playing oh and then I and then I
started not going into work yeah and I
started playing this game yeah and then
I started realizing how great it was and
again the dopaminergic kid and the high
was so great and so addictive but I
realized that that that short-term value
was replacing the long-term value that I
built in myself that I create and shape
in the world people want to know how do
you go from zero to six million
followers overnight how do you create
businesses three businesses that make
over a hundred million dollars listen
you don't wake up one day and express
value to the outside world again this is
something that you build every day you
you don't wake up and have a six-pack
right you don't wake up and have
um uh developed ideas and philosophies
these are things that stack and compound
over time and and then and then it
scales and then one day you have a
family and then your kids are respectful
they respect themselves they're strong
they're courageous and so I would push
back and I'll say I've had some of those
opportunities and I'm going to tell you
when I hung it up my wife had had
Striker or firstborn and she and she
says something and I'm like oh my God
like I'm bored out of my mind in here in
the hospital and I said I gotta go I
gotta go home I gotta go get something
all I wanted to do was play Halo oh yeah
it's all pretty badly well how much you
want to bet that's what a lot of people
think about they don't even do real life
because that other experience is so
Grand can I give you an a rebutt to that
well I'm almost done so just okay this
will take 10 seconds be done yeah I went
I played my last game I went home got on
immediately and I said I'm done forever
because because I was thinking about
this I felt bad I knew it wasn't right I
threw everything away and I never played
a video game again do you think you have
an addicted of personality that's what I
was getting at is potentially yeah no I
I understand why
well for me was uh it was role playing
there's a server and it tied into my
business as well obviously so it's like
doubly [ __ ] up but um but yeah I've
always struggled with addiction my
entire life so what I've tried to do
always is and the way I describe it is I
try to hyper focus on addictions that
are overall positive like Fitness
working out uh monitoring my calories
making sure that I have a healthy diet
uh or my work which I love you know what
I mean like Twitch streaming
um and and constantly improving myself
those are the things that I've hyper
focused on instead to because I know I'm
just going to be addicted to something
no matter what it is and I'd rather have
it be that instead of alcohol cigarettes
and even in certain instances video
games so that's how I've been able to to
you know get to the place I I've got to
which is pretty [ __ ] Primal isn't it
yeah no it is prime the question is is
it possible that you know first of all
you went and played Halo when your wife
was giving birth or like when she was in
that yeah so she was in the room with
the newborn and you're like [ __ ] Halo
time baby yeah like yeah so is it
possible that your own addictive
personality uh is is perhaps you're
seeing the world through your own lens
obviously because what are the lens do
we see it through right and it's
possible that you know a lot of other
people in the world can have a healthy
relationship with video games uh whereas
obviously you just go out all out I
believe everything in moderation is all
[ __ ] [ __ ] right um oh we don't
believe in moderation okay good I don't
no interest that's what I believe you
want to know you got to do uncommon
things right you want more in life which
virtually everybody does guess what you
got to do more in life and if and if you
apply moderation to everything and if
you're a jack of all trades you're a
king of nuns right you're a master of
none and so this is what I believe this
is what I do I go all in and then I
Outsource everything else I'm laser
focused and so this is what has allowed
me to to create resistance and to create
progress and my relative roles in my
life life right let me ask you this
Siddhartha the Buddha Primal or
subprimal you got to tell me more I
don't know because he was all about the
Center PATH moderation walk it down the
line everything in moderation I'll say
it [ __ ] it I'll say it he's a cow he's a
[ __ ] Tower
and by the way he wouldn't even eat he
would sit there and fast and eat like as
little rice as possible wow [ __ ]
beta of behavior well by the way fasting
is a primal practice but he was starving
uh we'll start well listen on purpose
it's okay so we start for five days a
quarter that's crazy we don't need any
calories for five days every quarter so
there are some practices there that I
would say are absolutely perfectly I
don't know anything else about Buddha or
that religion I think as we as we get to
talk and I think you're gonna guys are
gonna say um I know a lot about Primal
living I know a lot about ancestral
living again my my fight in the world is
we're going to talk a whole lot about
why people are hurting how people are
hurting and how there's an elegant
solution to returning people back to the
default strength health and happiness
and you're gonna say at the end of this
liver King don't know [ __ ] about Buddha
or religion or politics or policy I'm
good with that right I'm not plugged in
to that world I'm plugged into my Primal
bubble and indeed that's fine no I'm not
judging there's no judgment here
um
I want to go back to something
interesting though
because I the GMO topic I'm sorry to go
back because this is something I care
about
um I feel like they get a bad rep what
is it that's so Primal about the GMO I
just didn't understand it bottom line is
I just think Mother Nature had it right
Mother Nature had it right but then
where do you draw the line where Mother
Nature had it right because like surgery
you know cancer treatment I'll tell you
where I draw the line there is uh acute
medicine I'm all for it
I'm all for it but if Mother Nature had
it right and if we lived close to Mother
Nature and if we Embrace these nine
ancestral tenants all first principle
thinking based on Mother Nature had it
right it's all preventative this is the
thing no you don't we're not even
talking about surgery and cancer and and
depression and anxiety you look at these
modern day primitive culture tribes it's
non-existent these things are
non-existent eliminated the root cause
if you eliminate microplastics out of
your life for example this is what
you're saying right enough of that stuff
yeah yeah
I mean this is fair even though it's
true yeah no and I love how you were
talking about editing a stick like this
guy's social cerebral you can actually
justify anything this is you're one of
the most dangerous men probably to
yourself and to others
what you can justify people don't start
doing that I'm like oh [ __ ] he's just
writing well hold on liver I'm testing
the your logical uh facilities here
because rice GMO rice has saved
literally billions of lives because they
have the ability to fortified it with
vitamins that people who are
malnourished aren't getting they have
the ability to make rice flourish in
like different climates that we usually
die so are you four GMOs very much yeah
okay I think GMOs are prime I go back
and forth on jumos because like I I feel
like
um
I grew up in turkey and
you didn't have certain vegetables and
certain fruits and certain Seasons you
know what I mean like that was just not
the case when I was growing up and I
never saw like for example I never saw a
cucumber that was like this big until I
came to America and that [ __ ] is so
nasty luckily they now sell like Persian
cucumbers love the Persians yeah but
like that's what I grew up are you sure
they're not just different types of
cucumbers I don't think well I mean I
think it's still like modified every
every part of the every part of the
process to make like strawberries as big
and as juice so what's wrong with that
and Apple's as big and as juicy
um the only thing I have about it is not
that like oh man it's giving you cancer
or like making you gay or whatever I
don't I don't believe in any of that I
don't think that's true yeah yeah it is
yeah definitely
um of course but uh I I do think that
like the taste of it is more bland in a
weird way well that's a fair criticism
taste but I I pushed back when people
say like oh it's yeah
there's something that's my only issue
with it like I don't have a problem with
Jim Emos I just don't like uh I I don't
like when they try to like Drive the
most
profit out of like the same thing by
sure just basically constantly modifies
oh so like for example in lots of parts
of Asia they're like malnourished and
super deficient in certain vitamin types
and their main primary source of food is
is rice and as you know in China and
India there's so many people billions
and billions of people that uh during
times of dra a drought or like monsoons
uh food could become scarce and
unavailable and what they've managed to
do is make rice that's super resilient
to all these different weather sources
that is extra packed with vitamins that
helps them avoid malnourishment and so
this rice the specific rice that I'm
talking about has saved billions of
lives it's estimated so I think the GMOs
can actually when it's when you're
talking about like being able to feed
more people and uh making it more
resilient and because GMO you people say
there's not enough food
in the world to feed everyone that's not
even true right but I think yeah because
we can't transport like [ __ ] meat
from America and feed people in Africa
but because of GMOs it makes it possible
that people can eat cheaper
um and have more reliable food sources
you know I prefer massive populations
every once in a while like people start
talking about something going on halfway
across the world right and and they
don't even have their own lives in order
and how much you want to bet I just the
statistics I told you are Universal
right the 85 self-esteem 80 struggle
pitch all that stuff but our people are
really hurting and these are the same
people you know that don't have a penny
in their bank account and they're having
conversations about crypto investing
right they're talking about things
before they've had they've taken
personal responsibility and
accountability so what I generally say
to people is like guys we should
probably have this really candid
conversation over dinner but what I know
is going to serve the audience the best
is if you can take personal
responsibility if you can get your own
life in order by doing these nine
ancestral tenants if you can get your
own household in order go help your
neighbor once you can help your neighbor
go help your community once you can do
that we can go sit down at dinner and
then we can talk about policy or
politics but how if you don't have your
own life in order which most people
don't how are they talking about helping
other people to have their lives in
order and this this is just like being a
dad you have kids how many kids you have
two boys I thought so just like you but
boys cool yeah and here's the thing is
um I don't know if you believe this this
is what I believe is that we have a
single job to do as a parent as a dad
it's to affirm our kids with Adept the
challenge worth and potential that they
come to believe in themselves how can
you do that as a parent if you don't
believe in yourself you got to take that
personal accountability and
responsibility believe in yourself and
then affirm your kids that same way so
as we get to talking again I think it's
as simple as I believe in Mother Nature
sure had it right it's incredibly
nuanced obviously yeah right are doing
it here back home and we're way over fed
is this helping people out or is it
possibly to our detriment again this is
really new on stuff what I would say is
um do you guys know how many people a
day kill themselves
take a guess hmm probably like a couple
thousand probably in the United States
but worldwide it's between twenty five
hundred and four thousand one to one one
and a half million people kill
themselves a year yeah that's sad and
they have no hope there's no light at
the end of the tunnel and and you know
what's even more [ __ ] up is the
disproportionate number of men doing it
three and a half times more men do it
but you know what the most [ __ ] up
thing is there's a 20x multiplier on
attempts again a 20x multiplier on
attempts where they see no value no
worth no hope no potential in their
lives they take so this is what I try to
focus on but the 20x multiplier on
attempts is uh is disproportionately
towards women I think because men
if I'm not mistaken are more successful
or they use more violent means to to
complete it oh well that's an
interesting gender study right there no
that's like women for example Primal or
subprimal women yeah this is no
different than men
they were failing out on the well they
they used different means like I can't
believe you just asked that you should
be in trouble for asking that question
I've just pose the questions here like
the availability of Guns is a is a big
contributing factor to increasing
suicide rates and also uh part of it is
because
it literally factors into like men
having higher rates of suicide as well
because like they often use a gun rather
than and they know how to use it right
yeah but this this is my deal it's like
we're talking about GMOs halfway across
very very nuanced stuff let's talk about
what's in what's under our nose okay
thank you again let's go let's focus in
on the on the good [ __ ] okay well here
speaking of good [ __ ] what listen you
gave me the gifts right of of the
airplane yeah the penthouse yeah I can't
believe you sent me two luxury Vehicles
one for me and the queen it's over the
top I know but you deserve it can I
bring my best gifts actually you guys
please oh no liver King Chef Lionel
where are you at yeah oh my God you're
fat what the hell how did you guys
telepathically oh Jesus Christ yes so he
sit down and absolutely and so these
meats have been sitting out for a minute
now are this gonna give me a pair of uh
parasites worms it's Primal if you get
it everything Chef Jeffrey Dahmer here I
mean Lionel by the way are tapeworms
Primal or subprimal totally Primal man
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I'll pairs
yeah you lose you lose some weight if
you get some tapeworm effortlessly like
you probably we should all have a couple
tapeworms I would only be so lucky yeah
yeah okay Chef Lionel yes sir all right
I got some treats for y'all by the way
um we of course have our charcuterie
board not a normal charcuterie board but
we do have some
bone marrow this right here is gonna be
very fatty um it's probably I love bone
marrow love bone marrow we always eat it
at the temperature of the cat
I I I'm a big fan of bone marrow okay oh
like I see it when it's yeah let's find
out
you want me to hit it raw right now oh
yeah let's do it cheers yeah so um just
give me the the intel on this meat you
guys you guys are are feeding us raw
meat so how do you guys make sure that
it's like good yeah definitely so it's
just like a stick of butter yeah that's
what it feels like that's right I've had
raw uh bone marrow so so we treat this
exactly like sushi if we're not the ones
butchering it ourselves so if we butcher
it we'll eat it fresh right there we'll
save the blood and
um whenever you have some of these
pathogens that get in there is because
of just contamination and that's when we
try Panthers if you butchered the
animals and no it's just actually it's
not bad it's it's like butter it's like
about Flavor really yeah if you've never
had like uh like interesting like a
fancy restaurant if you've never had
like a bone marrow no I have I have it's
not raw like
we keep it like this just to keep all
the nutritional value in there we don't
want to lose anything we want to take
advantage of the full cow and it tastes
best when it's the temperature of a cow
right um it's like I want to also give
just a quick response to the pathogenic
load before we were apex predators we
were scavengers right we talked about
this we would eat stuff that had been
rotting for days and weeks we're meant
to take on a pathogenic load the pH of
our stomach is more acidic than a pure
carnivore the pH of our stomach is
similar to that of a complete scavenger
so we're meant to take on this path
though I mean look like but we have and
this is my point that's my point you can
put out a piece of meat for a couple of
months and you can you can have a bite a
day and you can start to build a
pathogenic resilient Hey listen if the
zombie apocalypse comes we're good to go
right and there's no refrigerators
everything's spoiling we can eat
anything everywhere so what I would say
is today we're having little bit bits of
this right and as pristine as he's kept
it you're still going to get a little
bit of a pathogenic look great my advice
to everybody oh you're going to be
completely I'm here for the path you are
so fun I'm not ready for that wait you
don't need any sushi actually not I
don't eat I don't eat any sushi do do
you guys really don't eat rice if you
have a steak how do you have it cooked
oh I I eat it medium rare to rare that's
fine
there's no different yeah but so so it
be it picks up the bacteria and stuff
during the processing probably in like
the processing plants and stuff like
that yeah so whenever we don't know
what's if someone else is butchering get
butchering it for us we're not going to
eat it raw fresh but what we normally do
whenever someone else is butchering it
for us well treat it like sushi and
we'll freeze it for at least seven days
smart and you know my main thing is to
not get liver King and his family six
and have you guys ever got sick from
Chef uh I'm sorry what was your name all
the [ __ ] time all the time so that
means nobody reached out to hire him
he's mine only you don't want him he
makes us sick every day and
come on they get sick of me I'm sure
we've never gotten sick but did you ever
put seasoning on this or you just go
Primal mode and raw eater yeah
I have a question when's the last time
you had like a like a McDonald's burger
[Laughter]
is it a good question like I'm so
curious I'll I'll tell you um
20 years ago whoa 20 years I mean listen
I think the Whopper is dog [ __ ] but like
every now and then you know what I mean
I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ] have a
burger every now and then do you eat
burgers oh you have burger patties all
the time but here's the thing I I can't
get food anywhere else that's more
delicious than the food that liver King
Chef Lionel prepares for us and and when
you think about this the relative
difference of going somewhere else and
knowing that the food number one will
not taste as good and number two how
destructive the seed oils are but most
people don't know this but all that [ __ ]
is cooked in seed oils and Seed oils
lead to cell necrosis which leads to
inflammation which leads to the chronic
diseases we're talking about this is one
of the compounding factors why we're
suffering today why would I ever want to
go seed oils the seeds are enemy or the
enemy of the people well seed oils are
are really rich in linoleic acid it's in
a mega six acid it's an extremely
inflammatory meaning of oat milk because
that's just bomb is oat milk real how
are you gonna milk an oat I don't know
look I when I was growing up I was a big
Dairy boy and I still obviously love
cheese love ice cream all that sort of
yeah let's eat this [ __ ] before it
starts rotting yeah
but yeah this is like a very almost
intimidating type of organ but my
personal favorite it's gonna be the
testicles these are both testicles right
here now what's the benefit of eating
the testes is that's going to make me
more virile am I gonna am I gonna be
able to to you put some in your mouth oh
my God put my hair up for this how's
that taste good and fresh
okay number one chance I want to be a
smart ass and I was going to taste like
strength power gains and yeah right yeah
I mean that means it's [ __ ] like exactly
this is pretty sus man we're about to
put balls in our mouth what's going on
I want you to let me know what it
reminds you of yeah it looks like
chicken which immediately I am worried
about because when I see that it doesn't
look this looks like a kind of meat you
want to cook
it does look like it is pretty good
cooked but
so what's the benefit of eating uh cow
testing it doesn't smell great like
supports like that's why it's called the
testicle right now that's why liver is
called the liver
there's specific peptides there's
enzymes there's cell signal there's all
these things in here I'm putting it down
yeah
you just swallow you didn't even chew
you didn't even taste it oh that does
not taste good he didn't even chew it
and he can do whatever I didn't know you
could [ __ ] deep throat like that
okay I'm gonna try it oh you [ __ ]
chew that I will
I'm a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you should throw up no way he's got it
it dude that is oh
you're fired you're good to go
no way you're joking don't do it
and you see what that says on there oh
he's got a surpivable we got a subtitle
spit bucket if you can't do it oh my God
liver but at least yeah listen you got
testicle in your mouth you done it that
was not a great experience it tastes
like that I would like to replace like
[ __ ] metal and
it doesn't taste good well here's the
thing I don't like that liver oh you're
gonna wait for it I gotta wash my hands
liver is like so uh we eat a lot of
liver in Turkey my favorite food is
actually cocoa which is sheep intestine
um which is what sheep intestine okay I
love uh sheep intestine it's one of my
favorite things to eat oh yeah and so
I'm like I'm used to eating um so
obviously like super well cleaned and
then they uh they cook it on this like
spinning thing like they do with done ad
and then
um and then they'll like cut it finely
with a lot of spices and uh onions and
peppers and like it's really spicy it's
really [ __ ] good and then they just
like put it in the middle of a bread
that they sit underneath the the the
fatty like the fat dripping into it
um I love it it's delicious liver is
another thing that we eat a lot in
Turkey I have never liked liver all
right
because
like the scent and the smell of liver I
don't really like it that much
um well then let's get down on some
liver
before it's out for too long I just I'm
being straight up with you guys that was
the one of the worst things I've ever
tasted and this man eats frozen pizzas
like all the time
here's the thing our palettes change our
pallets change right that's true and and
here and the deal is when I started
eating this way I really
this is going to sound very subprimal I
really didn't know how I was not going
to eat some of that processed food again
like the cookies and the donuts in fact
you're missing it I did yeah and are you
getting down on it right now yeah I'm
getting down here I'll follow suit
that son's chewing this time he didn't
deep throat it yeah it's really mild
yeah it's actually not that bad
um liver can be very what the [ __ ] is
that this right here is going to be our
travel blood travel blood yeah that's
right I want to finish my point because
um I didn't know how this traveled you
haven't had the liver
get on the liver and shut up for a
second okay all right sorry liver
because I I didn't know how I was going
to cut out the processed food and there
would be times I would sneak it nobody
would see me do it because I really
couldn't control it and then over a
couple of years I have zero inclination
the palette starts to change this stuff
to me is absolutely well actually the
testicle is not delicious
it's not good the liver is okay thank
you for at least saying that I thought I
was crazy so that tasted like [ __ ] to
you too it doesn't taste good no it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] but it doesn't
taste good that's how the testes always
taste you know what sometimes he makes
uh testicle ceviche
and you would love that that's got some
flavors all you would have to say I've
had liver
um cooked I think weirdly enough when
you cook it it draws more of the flavor
out of it and I don't like it yeah but I
had Raw Liver well that a friend of mine
uh prepared identical to like a poke
Bowl yeah and that was actually pretty
good it was like marinated with like
some sort of uh I think it was like some
sort of like Korean spice and that was
actually really [ __ ] good when I had
it like that
um I would I would rather eat it like
this than than cooked I don't know why
the the cooked liver is not that good
what's what's so special about liver as
I eat this go ahead I'll tell you
because this is why the name is liver
King
because if I can get this message out
you use a sub Primal spit bucket twice
I wish my kids were here to laugh at you
listen listen
I'm there's no I'm not here to prove
anything so far I will come before you
self uh proclaimed subprime I eat
[ __ ] I eat [ __ ] GMO apples and
everything I I know that you're Primal
and other capacities right and so I know
that you have it in you because it's
chewy it's tendini yeah and and what
what what's your favorite what the [ __ ]
is that wait you have too much stuff
going on in that what the [ __ ] is that
okay cheers
okay well what before I drink this what
the [ __ ] is that it's trouble blood what
is travel blog
it's a safe way we travel with blood
that we're able to uh how is it bring
over trouble with tell me about that
process so we freeze dry it and then we
could bring it over and then [ __ ]
blood I want to eat I want to share
something with you and drink it with you
so so you've it's like uh
it's like uh just have a little sip come
on just stop talking just do it I have
to analyze it it's a podcast oh that's
really good well see it's really good
yeah is it seasoning have you ever had
uh have you ever had broth like just raw
no I've never had broth that's on no I'm
just saying it's like it's a cold broth
okay let me try it the seasoning itself
is like the the blood blood has a flavor
towards it so whenever you put blood or
whenever you put like powdered kidney
powdered liver on some meat that season
itself like it has a British I don't
wanna I don't know if I want to drink
all of it prove to me how much you love
it I think a couple of sips you're good
to go it's like am I why do we consume
blood liver we've always done it right
since we didn't have time listen
um I want to answer the question about
the liver because you asked that
question
and here's the thing let me cheers if
you want to be an alpha organism kicking
an ass in life right you don't need to
know about all the all the peptides in
here you don't need to know about the
vitamins and minerals what what you need
to know that I got down if you want to
be an alpha organism do what other Alpha
organisms do right if you look at killer
whales they're the ultimate predators of
the sea they rip open great white sharks
and they go for the liver first Lions go
for the liver first the modern day
primitive culture tribes that go for
liver and they're kicking our ass in
life and so you want to know about all
the all the vitamins I can tell you that
there's really unique things in here
that you will otherwise that will
otherwise be absent in your diet if you
don't eat liver liver is the most
nutrient dense food that there is you
gotta find it listen you don't got to do
this
but you got to find a way to get in your
diet like you just do that stuck use a
cutting board Ethan we've just taken
this out of our diet and in Turkey they
still do it and a lot of other countries
we're still eating organs we've recently
abandoned the ways of our ancestors in
favor of muscle meat that falls off the
bone I just like the cooks is that a
dick I could eat this stuff is that a
penis
the enemy of good if you can get this
stuff cooked yeah cook it up sear it
starts talking about how delicious the
intestine the cultures have figured out
good yeah I I love sheep intestines bro
I'm not eating that [ __ ] that's that's a
bull penis dog you have to why are you
obsessed with eating dick and balls bro
well why not okay what do you like what
are you obsessing dick and balls bro I
like them raw in a different again like
supports like you know again that's why
the tissue is called what it is
that's sauce man
that looks super
tender but the thing is it's it's not
just dick and balls right you're just
gonna Force us raw dick right now we're
about to eat raw yo take me out for
dinner first man I guess you are
technically take me on a date first
before you feed me yeah this is our date
now is that like uh is that like uh dude
that is way too hard to cut what's
happening right now isn't pickled yeah
so okay interesting it is cooked um
because whenever you try to eat peanuts
Raw it's soft say that again whenever
you try to eat penis Raw it's soft but
it's really hard to eat whenever you
cook as soon as you put in boiling water
it turns hard but it's a lot easier to
eat and then we pickle it tender make it
even more tender yummy what do you
pickle it what's your pickling process
does this taste bad just vinegar and
salt okay uh I'll be honest it's pretty
much inedible yeah
hey we're going on the H3 podcast let's
let's do the legitimate legitimate
things and let's do some pickled pizzle
let me cut the tip of that [ __ ] like
oh Lorraine
uh what flashbacks I don't even know
what the so I I don't even know what
part of the [ __ ] I'm supposed to be
eating raw right that's it bro
so if you if you you don't like the
flavor of this so do you eat it
regardless because it's good for you or
if you're not [ __ ] with you don't like
the flavor this even though it's 100
what you said you know like um somebody
sold us that we're supposed to do things
that we like eat food that tastes good
right the foods that are best for us
probably don't taste great right and and
then when you're eating let's say you're
eating what's your favorite food
uh uh definitely uh fermented uh penis
for sure you look like the time yeah
what's your favorite food I don't know
no I'm not I'm not I like I like a steak
okay steak okay well I was hoping to use
another example let's just say for
people that like donuts or for people
that like crackers or whatever the [ __ ]
it is right how long does it take for
you to devour that most people it's like
a minute or two right so you just
enjoyed something that took a minute or
two to do harm to to you're going to
live in this body another 23 hours a day
right and so I still like to eat foods
that are delicious but I'm always gonna
eat the foods are the most nutritious
that's going to allow me to feel and
function and be my best right for most
of the life that I'm living got it so
I'm okay so I eat raw liver and raw bone
marrow and raw testicle every single day
you know the bone marrow was by far the
best on there the bone marrow was nice
good it's good yeah that's just butter
um look at that testing I don't even
know staring you down yeah
I'm never I'm never having that ever
again which was the testicle was not
good I know but you want to bet with
we're gonna do a part two and we'll have
testicles Ceviche how much you want to
say how much you want to bet you're
going to say I have seconds yeah I mean
Ceviche could be good but that's but
that's actually taking something that is
like unpleasant and turning it into
something pleasant like for me one of
the things I always tell uh people in my
community is like look your diet you
have to stick to it for the rest of your
life that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's a bad thing everything is a diet
you can have an unhealthy diet or you
can have a healthy diet and if you want
to make sure that you have a healthy
diet you have to make sure that you find
foods that you like that have decent
macronutrients and that you can get an
adequate amount of protein and and feel
uh like you are fulfilled and feel like
your stomach is full you know what I
mean like and what you're describing
with respect to like you know super carb
heavy Foods is is just that your body
processes it way faster it doesn't feel
you up in the same exact way it's like
processed sugar all that stuff's really
bad I think you can still every now and
then sneak in something if you want to
um
but
I I do think that like everything I do
at least I am a hedonist everything I do
I try to make sure that the food that I
eat I I eat chicken all the time I eat
chicken every day I love chicken you
like chicken but but I make sure that
that chicken is prepared in a way that
is uh still you know uh
fun to consume because I wanted to be
tasty sure so I whip it up in a way that
like it you know I still spice it a lot
and and you know make sure that it's
still uh consumable and good yeah well
here's the deal if you're not going to
be eating this stuff in the future again
you have to get this into your lives
right people in your community so I tell
everybody the best way to get
nose-to-tail organ Meats go on a hunt go
establish this kind of connection with
the animal and the land you'll never
look at taking an animal the same way it
changes everything it creates a
spiritual experience if you're not going
to do that I get it most people won't go
to a butcher look another man in the eye
shake his hand get to know where your
meat is coming from and if you're not
going to do that go to the grocery store
or go to one of these um online ranches
like white oak pastures is incredible
Piedmont tees is another one
um still people don't want to do that
because they don't want to taste it they
don't want it they don't want to procure
it they don't want to taste it they
don't want to put it down their mouth so
if you're not going to do that that's
where a supplement comes in you've again
we've recently over the last 100 or 200
years we took this nutrition out of our
diet to our detriment and now we're
suffering with deficiencies that year
that are measurable and so when I say
take a supplement you can take ancestral
supplements beef liver or bone marrow
these are your products this is the
hashtag ad yeah well that's fine no go
plug your [ __ ] bro well again at some
point you you need to get this stuff in
your life and I would say liver is King
because can I examine a 100 and where do
people are you examining I'm gonna go
pee real quick go to Amazon raised in
New Zealand grass-fed grass finished
this says it has asbestos in it just
kidding I thought you were smart I'm
just kidding because here's the deal you
got to get this nutrition I can't tell
you how many kids today so how do you
make these are diagnosed and prescribed
with conditions that are just nutrient
deficiencies and the mom hears from
another mom that they just started
giving their kid liver and bone marrow
and now that kid no longer expresses
those symptoms of their diagnosis right
the syntax and now they no longer need
that that stimul those types of
medications that are changing our
neurochemistry so if you can start by by
nutrition first when I say nature had it
right this is nature is it it's like I
mean let me tell you what we're talking
about Primal nature this doesn't is this
isn't doesn't summon that is that it's
the same thing yeah the only difference
is the moisture is taken out of that
but couldn't you say the same about GMO
it's just just because it's not as like
obviously accessible like in our
imagination that's the biggest [ __ ]
stretch of her is it could you say that
our early ancestors turned that into
that you say you see let me tell you I
mean you have it's it's in like a
plastic like what what's the gelatin
what do you think it was plastic it's
from the animal 100 of that is animal
products what about the bottles plastic
you got me
but here's the thing our early ancestors
they they dried this they made pemmican
right they stored it right and so this
is very evolutionarily consistent right
this is this this is ancestral you don't
have to taste it and once again remember
how I'm talking about this if you can go
procure this yourself there's not this
is what I do right the only time I take
ancestral supplements liver and bone
marrow and beef organs is when I'm
traveling otherwise I got liver King
Chef Lionel and liver Queen and liver
boys and I we're eating this every
single day just like this and so um
again this is the hierarchy I want
people to go out and get the real deal
The Real McCoy right if you're not
willing to do that you got to get this
in your life and so if I so I know
you're not going to be doing this
consistently no if if I can get you a
one month supply of this I'll take it
because I I just want an honest feel I
will I'll take it and I'll be honest
badass let's go okay I'll do the liver
King supplement uh yeah let's do it good
good I I appreciate you giving it a
chance you know it's gonna be really bad
bad marketing for you when he doesn't
change no stop it
the thing is I don't ever eat food like
this so if my body should be uh you know
uh deficient in it right or whatever
it's in there but most people when
they're deficient in it first thing they
say is I feel more energy okay and when
you feel more energy your mitochondrial
is starting to light up right your
mitochondria is starting to light up you
have more energy more drive more if yeah
it's perfectly Star Wars right um You
have more of the currency to take action
in life and so that's why I say start
with liver because we got all nine
ancestral tendons which I'm sure we're
not going to get into all of these today
but if you start with liver because
liver is King it's going to give you
more drive to dominate life my mom my
mom said cow dick all right mom sent a
message she says she texted Dan our
producer she says tell Ethan do not eat
the raw meat
wow how come why not uh can we get my
mom to call in Dan
I think that'd be interesting while
we're waiting she's just a worried
Jewish mother yeah she worries get her
on the phone dad so she didn't eat this
stuff when she was growing up what about
her parents dude they lived they both
lived nearly a hundred and they they
grew up eating like goddamn
uh like process the most processed food
imaginable because they grew up like
almost like Depression era so they were
eating like spam and okay question all
kinds of gnarlies steroids Testaments
steroids Primal or cell Primal steroids
Primal sub Primal
surprise why I I like steroids I I I do
take steroids no but the only reason why
I don't take it is because I'm like
afraid that I'm going to want to cycle
all the time and Chase the the
testosterone boost that you get from it
and that is one of the main reasons why
I've stayed away from it like I see it
literally like the same I treat it the
same way I treat cocaine I'll probably
do trt once I once my T levels start uh
I don't believe you I I think after we
get to know each other and you get to
know the nine ancestral tenants and you
get to understand and this stuff is in
the literature if you want
evidence-based literature instead of the
Bro signs Google this you and use Google
Scholar you'll find this in the
literature 50 years ago we had 50 higher
testosterone today people take steroids
to increase their testosterone by 50 so
why not just do these ancestral
Tendencies I mean I got good T levels
currently I'm just saying you say
they're good because that's the new
normal and that's the relative
difference but how much you want to bet
you could double your testosterone
Naturally by doing these nine ancestral
tenants what like [ __ ] simulator
why do we need so much testosterone does
it just make your hair fall out and like
make you impotent when you have too much
oh yeah no no I didn't take the HT
blockers uh technically finasteride
that's subprimal it's like that's a the
hormone uh DHD blocker like for my hair
and minoxidil do you ever take off your
hat yeah here we go oh beautiful you
have a beautiful I don't know if you
guys have heard this but uh so a year
ago maybe two years ago it was all about
like Peds and steroids right and and
then you know same question same answer
I didn't touch the stuff don't touch the
stuff right and then I think the haters
okay this got old so then I don't know
if you've heard this but liver King got
AB implants I've heard that that was the
thing that that I got to happen right
and then after AB implants it was you
know liver King always wore a hat then
he took off the hat you know why because
he got hair implants no you got real
hair oh I know I got real hair beautiful
hair and and then people started saying
oh well I shaved my body and you know
what I don't grow a lot of hair on my
body but can you tell me no you didn't
shave I don't shave my [ __ ] body no
um and then people started saying I had
Gene editing done but you know why they
said that but is that possible well I'm
the one who actually said that I'm like
hey if we're gonna have these ridiculous
accusations I'm gonna have some
ridiculous fun listen the only
accusation that's true is that I do have
a Polish PhD chemist on staff he does
make designer drugs that are
undetectable by any technology this is
the only thing that's true which is also
obviously a [ __ ] joke right oh damn I
was like hit me up
hold on just for fun this will be a
sound bite and I guarantee because this
is all over the place I re people really
say oh here's the sound bite hey you
said it yourself you said that you have
AB implants right and they don't listen
to the whole thing again you're going to
make these accusations I'm going to have
fun I want to say a lot of people accuse
you of taking steroids from Joe Rogan up
which I'm glad you're gonna go and show
confront that and Hassan
and he's a gym rapper I'm not I don't
know I have no problem steroids for the
record so no I know but but he says he
doesn't right so we gotta so we have to
uh now how
people say it's not possible to have
that body at your age
is it possible if he's like no no it is
possible it is I think I think that's
what Joe Rogan said right what all comes
down to hormones plus I've conclusively
proved that I'm there's a YouTube video
where we had a legitimate doctor come on
get a blood test yeah I mean if you
Google a liver King blood work you can
pull it up and you know we go over
everything but but here's the thing what
what this comes down to 100 of the time
is is hormone optimization and it's the
nine ancestral tenants I'm gonna get
through four of them right um all nine
it's here they are sleep eat move Shield
connect cold Sun fight and bond you say
cold cold thermal pressures right if you
sleep like [ __ ] you're gonna tank your
testosterone by 50 and you don't realize
this but how much you want to bet
relatively to the relative optim way you
could optimize sleeping you're sleeping
like [ __ ] you're if you just could sleep
better you would increase your
testosterone probably by 30 or 40
percent right and this is a fact and
your neurochemistry that the same thing
goes with how you eat and how you move
if you move like [ __ ] and if you don't
lift heavy [ __ ] you're not optimizing
your testosterone right okay if you keep
your in the fourth ancestral 10 in a
shield if you keep your cell phone next
to your dick and balls or that close to
you and you have ionizing radiation if
you're heating up your this is my pocket
right now holy [ __ ] and again these
little things Hassan it's these little
things that all stacking when I was
younger I was afraid of that but I don't
know I actually kind of gave up on that
I don't think that's right don't give up
on it you don't think what yeah the
whole the wife you have you think Wi-Fi
but I just said ionizing radiation right
this is in the literature this is why
the cell phone companies say don't keep
it within two inches of your head how
often do you know what how many is it
two centimeters I don't think they have
any oh 100 the risk so this is this is
I'll I'll forcefully push back on this
this is the the known ionizing radiation
which equals heat right there's other
things we talk about which is which are
non-ionizing radiation talking about
heat uh like having having like a like a
thing that produces heat so close to
yourself that's what that is and that's
on your dick and balls yeah no that's
that's basic that's basic I have to
correct you ionizing radiation is not
heat it's it has to do with like the
energy that can remove uh atoms and
stuff for molecules so that so that's
the kind of stuff that would cause
cancer like energy coming off radiation
I I do think that heat like having a
heat let's just say in your laptop like
having a laptop on your lap like that
stuff is not good for you but that's
just basic stuff you shouldn't be
heating oh but that's way different than
like being able to edit your DNA I yeah
heating your balls obviously that's why
your balls that's what you're doing
there's people that do no but there's no
heat coming off this hold on there's no
heat coming off that feel it I don't
have to feel it room temperature dude
trust me it's not room temperature
there's definitely if it's in your
pocket there is a there's a it's it's
sending and receiving data yeah but your
balls it can negatively affect your
balls if it's like heating them up like
10 but let me tell you what's what's the
benefits
it's a little bit warmer listen screen
just turned on what what's the purpose
what's the purpose of keeping it there
why not head
why not hedge how many kids do you have
you have two and you got a beautiful
wife yeah right do you want to be around
for them he's trying to get a vasectomy
personally like that yeah but I don't
think I I personally based on what I've
read and uh what I understand of the
science is that cell phones do not
produce enough radiation AKA heat they
don't do ionizing radiation but the heat
they produce is not enough to cause any
damage to anything I'm good with
everything it's just absolutely you know
it's interesting from outer space
there's way deadlier uh that's all
Native radiation but but I'm saying
there it's more powerful and and it's
coming through
it's completely different we've never
been exposed with the types of
non-native things that we've invented
we've never been exposed this is all an
experiment let me say this you you can
believe whatever you want to believe but
why not when you sleep at night put it
in airplane mode
when you're sleeping at night oh sure
yeah right when you're sleeping at night
why not put your Wi-Fi on a timer you
don't need your Wi-Fi when you're
sleeping at home do you no no no no okay
and what we do is we turn off all the
electricity at night I'm not saying go
that far but when you sleep this is the
most important part of the day where
you're going to recover and reload and
recalibrate where you're going to heal
so why not hedge listen there's yeah
there's no conclusion you've got to
figure out where are the incentives to
actually do these multi-million dollar
studies to do this and this is just part
of the category of Shield my main point
which we've gotten off on this tangent
is if you do these nine ancestral
tenants what you're going to do is
you're going to optimize your hormones
your testosterone will at least be 30 to
40 to 50 if not 100 higher than what it
is and then these benefits that can
compound over time I mean yeah what
you're what you're describing is is you
know uh I mean I it's gonna come across
as dismissive as what I'm saying but
what you're describing is basic concepts
that I 100 agree with it's just like a
little bit of marketing associate shaded
with it like you're making it more fun
for people to follow along but like yeah
you're saying don't be sedentary move
around which is incredibly important and
also yeah and and you know uh engaging
something that's like physically
challenging I agree and also sleep well
which is anyone that thinks that that's
wrong or bad is just Incorrect and those
are the first four tenants right but
thermal pressures it's a legitimate deal
when you go visit any primitive culture
in the world they do all these things
they get the sun they don't they don't
slather their skin in sunblock and wear
glows all the time right there's no
technology they don't have phones
there's no there's no antennas
you use sunscreen ever no right but you
know but you know in Africa obviously
our our ancestors had dark skin to to
compensate for the amount of sun they
got your ancestors based on your skin
color probably come from from Europe or
Northern countries and so obviously they
adapted to wearing clothing and that's
what and not having the Sun so much and
that's why well what they adapted to her
is a different latitude right a
different strength of sun right because
because
thousands of years of evolution with one
generation though right but but within
three generations what you can do is you
can become infertile and within three
generations you could become fertile
again right this is called genetic
momentum right and this is why I'm
talking about what I'm talking about I
like that you said that I put a
marketing spin on it but this is this
was never my message that I invented
this is the message of our early
ancestors of your ancestors right all
I've done is I've studied these
primitive culture tribes I've gone and
I've lived with them and I've organized
this into these nine ancestral tenants
and and I so again I try to make it
simple I say hey let's all just start by
eating liver if you start feeling better
that's one liver well it's it's eat eat
but but but again if I if I tell you
everything it's like a golf swing you're
not gonna do [ __ ] right if I tell you
how to do an Olympic lift you're not
going to tell you all nine you're not
gonna do so so start with liver because
liver is King in 30 days we're going to
talk and you're going to say you know
what I feel better I'm in a better mood
and then you're going to say what's next
and I'm going to say okay stack the Sun
and the Earth okay what's next that's a
small order and then the small order is
just put the phone in airplane mode when
we sleep okay what's next okay little
[ __ ] like I'm excited liver but the one
thing I'll say about the liver is that
it's like very fatty so obviously if
you're like main form of consumption is
liver you're gonna get [ __ ] gout you
know what I mean but I guess
isn't that how you do it it's like high
uh it's like the the quality of fat
that's how you get gout is like when you
eat like super fatty not fatty foods but
the type of fat that liver contains is
what uh causes you to get gout I mean
gout and purines is mainly from
carbohydrates
um and which by the way is
very a lot of people got Gout a lot of
people that especially rich people that
uh it was it was considered like the
rich man's disease right back in the day
like the king's disease but yeah they
ate a lot of fatty uh liver and and uh
these like complex uh fats they were
consuming that and then they got Gout so
what you're saying is that you can eat
too much meat yeah 100 all right that's
what I do that's what I do
yeah that's an attack on what yeah yeah
he loves meat like I I love eating meat
I'm a huge fan I eat a lot of meat I
love steaks I love all sorts of
different lamb meat I don't eat any
Seafood yeah uh which is probably [ __ ]
up but I just can't I don't I can't you
don't like it it's okay I don't like it
but um I do still want to put fiber in
there you know what I mean I gotta I
gotta eat some greens to make sure that
there's like uh you know it's it's a at
least a little bit balanced like okay
you're healthy there ain't no primitive
cultural tribe that has gout there ain't
nobody that I know that because they
don't get that much meat I don't eat
that much liver depend of culture tribes
because meat was probably the first
thing they eat but I think meat was like
a luxury for them because they were
mostly foragers permanent culture how
many times do they have it I love it
when people say this I'm like hey man I
read all the same books you've read yeah
right I've actually gone and I've lived
with them I've hunted with them they
don't need berries with them if we come
across a bush of berries we'll pick some
berries if we come across a baobao tree
with a honey nest with a bee nest we'll
pick out some Honeycombs and we'll get
bitten right opportunity is a moving
Target when it's right in front of you
better [ __ ] seize it when you see
calories in a life where you don't know
where your calories are going to come
you take it but 99 of the calories are
coming coming from nose-to-tail foods
are they farm would you say what'd you
say I said no way I'm there they don't
farm at all I know you are but they
don't gather they Farm they Farm that's
how we that's how we perimeters you know
how we came out of the cave agriculture
well how recent is when did we start
farming
a couple thousand years several thousand
years we've got three million years 10
000 years maybe we got three million
years of our evolutionary history and
the smallest fraction of our time we
started doing that yeah but that's when
all everything happened
all I'm saying is the smallest fraction
of our time we started doing that right
but my thesis is yeah primitive
primitive detriment this man is this man
is is preaching the gospel to Karl Marx
I'm just gonna say he said Karl Marx
Primal is called Karma's family you guys
can say whatever you say you know you're
not touching that again this is what I
know you go visit with these people
they're the most beautiful they don't
farm this position there's no Farm
Really absolutely
everyone's a little bit different but
I'll tell you about the Hudson um I'll
just give you two examples the Hud's on
the Messiah right so the Hudson
um they
uh every day is a brand new day and they
go on a hunt every day and if they're
successful in the hunt they eat if
they're not successful they don't eat
that's all it is every single day which
is why they're at a fat deficit which is
why it's like hard for them to why do
you say they're at a fat deficit well
because like you said if you're fasting
if you're not getting like you know
they're usually successful in the hunt
and and when they get large game they
get plenty of fat and and we we consumed
a lot of fat with them I mean if the
whole village is eating one animal's
liver they're not gonna eat like a full
that's why it was considered like you
got a 20 pound lever have you seen a
whole liver before I mean it's big huge
yeah and let me tell you about about the
Messiah so that's just a Hudson right um
the Maasai they eat three things it's
milk blood and meat they're pastoralist
and that's all they eat milk blood and
meat how many members of the tribe and
the band that we we were well we
actually were with
um two or three different bands of the
missile say there's about 20 or 30. Okay
small small little tribes small
efficient they knew exactly what the
role was interesting um but but you look
at how they're eating and how they're
kicking ass in life how happy they're
how beautiful they are they're just
positions trust me when I tell you you
want some of what I know but they've
never watched anime
which is I'm just saying like like yeah
no they're great they're having fun but
like I I feel like I could give one of
them an aneurysm by showing them like a
Twitter post you know what I mean like
they would be like what the [ __ ] is this
which I like that stuff I I think my
cameraman gave him an aneurysm when he
brought his drone yeah and everybody
wanted to fly the Drone you know like
that's what I'm saying by the way but
that's cool my mom is on standby let's
just bring her on real fast uh she's a
cautioning well what the one thing we
haven't eaten is the penis that's
actually cooked we're gonna forget it
and Hassan go ahead and eat that peanut
no no no no we're eating it together I'm
not eating it by myself well you started
off I've got to talk to my mom though
I just no I have not ever tried uh
I just I'm not doing this without you
I'm gonna do it I promise I just want
you to go first why do you want me to go
first like which part of it which part
of it should I try oh the tip definitely
got the drum roll baby you play just the
tip never heard of it oh okay
[Music]
dude you're you're punishing I know if
liver King says it's bad man I can only
imagine because I called you sub Primal
it's like I am so Primal I don't I don't
want to fight it this is dude that's a
fat oh wait a minute it has some of the
testicle juice on there also
besties for this is the tip of the penis
is that that's officially the same yeah
the other part is that is that
considered the the it smells filet
mignon
about to find out I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be able to have the whole thing
it's gummy it's like gum it's like gum
yeah yeah you can't you can't [ __ ]
it's Primal gum Chef do you like this
food on your on your free time when
you're at home with your family do you
eat this stuff I love working with it
because it's you know raw organs is
something so sinewy
yeah you don't have to swallow it I can
hear the crunch
well let's see I don't know hi I'm dick
tips
having a hard sun is chewing he's having
a hard time yeah he's oh he's he's put
just down that dick dude
[Applause]
well hold on
hold on I gotta ask my mom for
permission first she wants something
well here she is okay Mom uh yeah we're
here with liver King this is my mom you
used to urge me against
nice to meet you yeah hi she he's our
you're urging me not to eat the raw meat
is that right
I mean if you get a real like you just
kill the meat and it's really fresh I
mean if you want to eat it I actually
just submit you that you're thank you so
much for the she just gave her blessings
yeah so so they say I mean like kill the
animal no it's just well Mom hold on let
I'll have them explain the uh life cycle
of this meat and then you can deem if
it's uh worthy or not so sweet Chef go
ahead I did cook the peanuts so the the
penis isn't raw so you have a blessing
to eat the penis yeah the penis is is
pickled is that okay it's pickled it's
cooked
listen everything else is ancient
history we've already had all the other
rocks yeah yeah unfortunately
unfortunately you're a little late
you never I saw that I was texting
dancing don't
Olia mother's love all right anything
you want to say to liver King mom
the same thing about liver
liver
um if you're really anemic liver is a
really important thing to eat cook but
your mom's very final by the way
agreed all right so you're saying cook
that my mom says cook the liver not raw
liver my mom
two uh rules of thought because liver is
what purifies all the yuck in your body
so it goes through your liver in the old
days doctors used to say oh make sure
that you eat liver once a week and then
doctors were saying ah not so good
because of all these impurities yeah the
the liver does detox
um but but it doesn't but it doesn't
store toxins right it's a filter to
conjugate for path for for detox
Pathways one and two but it doesn't
store toxins there it is there's two
rules of thought but I know that it's
really rich in iron but you want to eat
it cooked
oh there it is my mom has agreed to
disagree
agree to disagree but when you were
growing up did you eat liver oh I don't
know she loves liver and this is what I
was saying earlier like with the the
genetic momentum that we had
um our our own parents and grandparents
and forefathers in perpetuity eight nose
to tail had this robust strength in
health and we're re we're now recently
losing that and and we're abandoning
these ways and so it's really
interesting to me that our own parents
ain't this way our own grandparents come
for liver well I don't care how you get
it right right right I don't care how
you get it yeah I think there are other
factors all right thank you Mom
appreciate that all right all right they
said you're Primal by the way very
primal
yeah you got the Primal stamp of
approval all right thank you
you've got a blessing dude what the [ __ ]
is the size of that yeah dog come on put
that [ __ ] in your mouth okay well first
of all
I'll just cut you a bigger piece
they're all gnarly bro even the rest of
them are gnarly are you calling my food
not gnarly sorry Chef sorry I forgive
you
but this piece seems like extra
scenery they're all scenery it's like
yeah see how hard that was cut sure
small that counts what that's such a
baby piece you're literally getting I'm
gonna spit it out I'll just be real with
you okay just no no I have a full thing
have that full thing have that full
thing no I'm gonna cut because I'll just
be honest with you if the whole thing is
not going down I'll just I just want to
give it the best shot I can
let's face it none of it's going down
it's going in the mouth just do your
best you you can put that wrong don't be
using that beta sound bite it's not
wrong
they're calling me betas but here's the
thing if you get this down it it will
overshadow that sub problem
let's do it that's a sigma
you know what Sigma male is what is it
it's a man who walks his own path he's
not or Alpha Norbit yeah so I I accept
that moniker okay cheers guys I'm about
to redeem myself
why you can hear it you can hear it
oh he's doing it
why is it like that why do you eat this
liver
for your for your dick to get uh
healthier right it's just gonna make my
dick harder
I'll throw a second I always have
I know now you're gonna have one you
wake up tomorrow you're welcome budding
you are welcome
Blackbeard from Popeye the Sailor Man
the way oh you got it on that you got it
yeah take a little water put it down
you do it you got it you have to put it
down or else you're going to spend oh
you're that close man you're that close
you're so close let's go Sigma
it won't go down this is the best
episodes
it won't go down just you suck on it
just I've already absorbed all the
flavor just knock it back like it's a
pill
[Music]
yeah drink some water come on or some
blood
no beta sound bites have a sigma
Sigma the sound much
I chewed it it's like well I can't do it
you got this
take a deep breath and swallow I don't
know why my body is resisting
there we go
it's all in the brain
or the penis this is how I felt when you
made me eat that [ __ ] frozen pizza
[Music]
[Laughter]
especially some of the frozen pizza this
is still good you got it
no he just keeps drinking more water
it's too much you got you got some of it
down okay spit it out let's move on we
got the subprival bucket next to you
holy [ __ ] have you had any of it
oh
[Laughter]
man you tried you tried but you failed I
chewed it up liver I I did more than him
I tasted that Jack I'd chewed it I
experienced it he took it back though
the catastrophic failure you know I
think God Hassan is on here just looked
like a champ I mean I I like everything
that grows on the land I'll eat all
kinds of land meat but I can't eat any
[ __ ] Seafood I hate it it's all in my
mouth
um
that was
that was sub-optimal
thank you so much well this was a great
eating experience oh my God like I said
you know you you sent me all these
incredible gifts to be here today and I
thought you know I got to reciprocate
thank you so much yeah this is
not a great gift I'm gonna be honest
yeah maybe next time should we leave the
Pickled penis for another guest
you know how long does that stay
preserved apart for a good week oh just
a week it could be more but we we open
it already so once you open it that's
whenever the children started it's very
conservative when it comes to this yeah
I mean that's good it is good yeah it is
good but I wanted to ask you more
questions so when you're at home do you
eat the raw meats or no um I took this
supplements
um with raw meats I'm a chef my job is
to make these as tasty as possible
because you taste them yourself someone
who is not raised off of liver reading
eating raw liver is not going to be good
um and so wait what the [ __ ] we just did
wait what yeah where's the saw that it's
not supposed to be good though this is
the nutritional value
from a taste then it's all about the the
nutrition yeah and so what's your
specialty my specialty yeah
um
I grew up do you make like a certain
type of Cuisine I was trained off I was
trained from French and Italian chef so
a lot of my food is fresh and Italian
inspired in the sense of I don't use too
many spices which with the liver King
family
um you don't want to use too many spices
you want the flavor to come from the
organs you want to try to bring out as
much of that or if you haven't had Raw
Liver fresh from the cow it's so much
more sweet and so you want to try to
bring out those flavors not hide them
but just compliment them and let be
honest with me you are you have a family
you have two boys and a wife
do you make them eat this [ __ ] I don't
make them they they all eat do you think
they you think they sneak in a like a
Krispy Kreme every now and then you know
no no no no we're boys my boys would do
that I would disown them yeah
and liver green and I would start
working on another boy right now oh no
right now
um but but that's what I always say have
they ever tasted the delicious nectar of
the Gods Diet Mountain Dew
that's mine because like look I I eat
you know a lot of meat and a lot of
healthy stuff but like that is my
weakness I understand it I [ __ ] love
diet mountains
do you give do you give your kids a
choice on what they're gonna eat
yeah
yeah they don't like something but you
have a little how old is your I mean
he's three and six months so they're
they're young and you give your your
three-year-old a choice
[ __ ] no
well because here's the deal if you
really give your kids to be eating
crayons and [ __ ] they're three right
but because there's something that
that's happened in our culture recently
we're like oh yeah you should let your
kids choose whatever they want to do
right and then you should support that
and then you should be their best friend
and then guess what you should be
responsible for them growing up and
hating their lives no my parents my
parents said let me see people diet and
that's the reason why my entire family's
obese I grew up obese as well 100 I will
control what my children eat yeah no it
wasn't good like uh 100 I will control
what my children eat but I also do think
that like every now and then they can
have like a little you know little treat
every now and then yeah you know if you
build the biological resilience they're
going to be able to withstand some of
that poison this is why we drink alcohol
this is what this is why we still
indulge in Wi-Fi every once in a while
but here's the deal if you give your
kids a choice do you want to eat a pile
of liver or a pile of donuts what will
they choose if you give them a choice
hey you're going to go work out there no
way your kids are choosing a pile of
liver though but you know this is why I
don't let them choose this is the point
this is exactly the point I do not give
them the choice right categorically
speaking if you were to give them the
choice they're going to choose the path
of least resistance don't you worry that
the like uh relapse though because like
this is something I see a lot where like
children want to be
um you know they got a little Anarchist
streak in them right so they like want
to go against their their uh you know
parents and how they were raised don't
you worry that they're going to become
like you know donut consumers later on
so again if you give them a choice if
they want to get in the cold plunge or
if they just want to go chill on the
couch what are they going to choose
right and so the way that we're raising
them if I'm worried about that I'll tell
you what I'm worried about
um I told you earlier I have one job to
do as a dad to affirm them with the
depth of challenge worth and potential
so that they come to believe in
themselves they know extreme ownership
leadership responsibility over the exact
life that they shape and create when you
have power that true ultimate dominion
over self when you realize that every
action you can prospectively Define and
shape and create you wanna that life you
want to live in
I'm okay if they hate me I've always
said this I've said this multiple times
I would rather you hate me than you hate
yourself I'm giving them the the
Weaponry so that they know how to lead
their lives and am I worried about them
relapsing you got to remember my why in
the world is that my kids couldn't
breathe my kids were allergic to
everything they were going to the
hospital because of the [ __ ] that I was
feeding them and then I had the solution
my way out of this that they couldn't
breathe they were always wheezing they
had bags around their eyes that going to
sleep your kids were sick they were they
were horrifically really like asthma and
stuff again it was like chronic and they
couldn't breathe how old were they when
this was happening they were babies oh
they were they were young yeah isn't
that good though like you get I mean I
was apparently very sick as a child and
like now I just never really a kid yeah
how many times did you go to the
hospital because you couldn't breathe
did the ambulance have to pick you up
because I don't I think like I was
literally not supposed to be born like
my uh at the time they were in London my
dad was getting is a doctorate of the
London School of economics and there's
the general practitioner was like yeah
we gotta abort this [ __ ] child yeah
this [ __ ] doctor said and he was like
nah [ __ ] it he said [ __ ] it we ball okay
I'm interested in what you're saying
because so is this one the liver King
was born 100 it was okay because we did
it out of medical necessity because
every doctor has given us more Benadryl
and more epipens I'm done with that
solution right all we're doing is
sedating them and medicating them and
they can't go out and explore the world
because guess what you need to have an
EpiPen and Benadryl around him all the
time and then you got to coach people on
how to use it because they were turning
blue and the ambulance was coming to
pick them and so um how did you discover
this new path that that to address I
just started reading I just started
reading as many books as I could and
then finally I Came Upon a book Sally
Fallon wrote this book nourishing
traditions and and I it was all about
and the ancestral way of living and it
made sense to me it made sense to me
that the way that we've lived for
millions of years to heal and be health
healthy is what we still expect today in
the modern world to heal and be healthy
and I said holy [ __ ] is it possible the
food that we're giving them could be
making them sick and and so what did you
start feeding them like this was
probably the most interesting thing
right so we cleaned house so I'm I'm
gonna answer all this I'm not worried
about relapse because where we came from
right because where we came from and and
then if they want to go out and do some
stupid [ __ ] when they're older they're
so robust and they're so resilient they
can take that [ __ ] on now but because
what we ended up doing is we ended up
cleaning house everything we threw
everything out guess what they ate what
they eat nothing nothing they wouldn't
eat nothing oh they were they they
weren't into any of the food but because
the first foods are like bone broth I
suspect you don't want to eat the
[ __ ] liver you want to eat liver and
bone broth when you're four guess what
they they would eat nothing and and then
their my wife's parents came over and uh
and said I can't believe you're doing
this to your kids and she started crying
it was like two or three days they're
having herzheimer detox reactions that
it's like a microbial die off and they
look sick you starved her too you were
like nah we're eating liver in this
house that's right God damn yeah but but
really all about the kids I I said you
know what I'm not going back to that
hellhole my kids need a better life and
this is the path to that better life so
I told her we're doing this and thank
God within about a day when you don't
eat for about three days you'll eat
anything right and so we would put the
liver in front of the kids for breakfast
lunch and dinner I'm like hey guess
what's coming for the next meal Raw
Liver it's gonna be liver again always a
cooked liver
um I think it was actually steamed liver
wasn't it it was cut
guess what when you're hungry you'll eat
anything yeah and then guess what your
palate changes your whole physiology
changes the light bulb comes on the bags
around their eyes go away now they're
breathing without no wheezing there's no
problem there's no resistance and a
personality emerges interesting that you
you feel so guilty that you that you
were pushing that personality back for
that many years and and how did you
decide on Raw Liver
yeah well again the Sally Fallon she
talks about this in her book lesson 8
price talks a lot about this Natasha
Campbell McBride and the gaps they talk
a lot about this uh and this is an
evolutionarily consistent foods that
have the least amount of of issues when
you introduce into people that are
really sensitive I see so so in these in
this literature they they said the raw
the liver is it's probably like three
things it's like it's you start with
like bone broth and then a few days
later when you don't have any reactions
to bone broth like you introduce some
some raw liver and then you introduce
egg yolks and then you start introducing
like there's there's kind of like a
protocol to it it sounds like they have
some kind of food allergy have you been
able to figure out what kind of foods we
had them tested a million times really
we couldn't figure out what was causing
what you know and again like they would
touch a dog they would break out in
hives wow does that sound like a food
allergy I mean they would break out it
just sounds like they're very yeah have
a lot of allergies there's something
going on from uh immunologic standpoint
right right and again when you can't
breathe okay enough is enough yeah
that's scary I guess and then listen
there's no dog and there's no food
around and they and they go into an
attack and there's something about dust
and whatever substance what's what's in
there if you're on dogs now now they're
good to go oh now they're strong as
oxygen you don't want to deprive them of
that dogs are great I love dogs we got a
pack of Dobermans at the house and I was
so concerned when we first got dogs
that's why he doesn't need to have Wi-Fi
anymore he's got he still has security
yeah that's right well I said I said I
eat a lot broad liver oh they just like
us but I I said I pray to God that that
um they're not going to be allergic to
the Dobermans because I do not want to
have to get rid of one of my friends
right right you know yeah not right
right because everything is good right
everything is good everything worked out
but but remember you ask am I worried
about them relapsing if you understood
where we came from why we had to do this
how we've rescued them the the Kick-Ass
life that they're living now the drive
that they have the strength that they
have the courage and Mastery that they
have in their lives like I know that
we're on the right path
do they go to public school or they home
taught like how does that work yeah
homeschool okay yeah because out in the
world if you go to like you know public
school they're eating pizza yeah they've
got a Michelle Obama special and you we
can't expose them to that right
um no they can be exposed to all this I
mean even when they were going to bring
it they're bringing a little lunch boxes
like boom open it up it's just liver
that's what they did what that's what
they did they would open up the lunch
box and they would have a rib eye steak
that would have their liver they would
have their bone marrow and it was cooked
a lot some of it was raw but the cool
thing how do you keep that fresh to the
school it doesn't have to be fresh again
people think I can eat this in five
hours I can eat this in three days right
again we slowly acclimate and they're
not gonna be chewing on that like a
bully stick yo by the way that is
literally what dogs yeah I know it's
thick yeah it smells so [ __ ] yeah
it's so bad so did you ever get
complaints from like teachers or peers
being like yo what the [ __ ] are you
feeding your kid you know what we've had
CPS called on us really she doesn't
really like me talking about this but
God damn here's the thing anything that
you do that's different when did that
happen it was I don't know a couple
months ago the Foster system is probably
worse than eating raw liver oh yeah I'll
admit that Foster yeah wow so this
happened a few months ago so they
actually came and checked up on the
family yeah yeah but because somebody
reported that we made our kids drink
blood when we were the Maasai and so
they interviewed them did your parents
make you drink blood and then our boys
said we're with the Messiah if you're
drinking if the Messiah drinking blood
and they offer you blood you drink blood
you know do your parents make you cold
plunge and this 34 degree water no we we
choose to do it so are they liver
princes is that what it is I would never
use that word I I call them Savage liver
boys okay you don't like the word Prince
you know what I just I don't even know
what it is uh but I caught so we have
Striker the Barbarian well a prince is
the son of a king oh thank you well I
just you said you didn't know what it
was like literally you know but what
yeah I'm just saying yeah you know
here's the thing they're forging their
own path right somebody asked the other
day if uh they asked them do you want to
be like liver King one day you know and
they started to answer that question I'm
like you know what I'm gonna answer this
if they turn out to be like me we'll
have catastrophically failed right like
that they're going to be so much better
and this is how it should be right if
you do your job as a parent your child
is so much better than you and so
whatever path so so for by default if I
even call them princes and now they're
in line to be the keying [ __ ] all that
that's why I'm like I don't really like
that name I don't like that connotation
you know uh thank you for defining what
it what about oh you're welcome yeah
abolish the man Anarchy yeah that was
interesting
well you know sometimes the princes come
for the dad's head because they want to
rule and we can't be having that I've
already told my kids you're gonna have
to fight me to the [ __ ] death man and
that's why I work out twice a day and
train the way that I do because bring it
[ __ ] they're gonna be big strong well
they have a head start on you so that's
what I've been saying that's what I've
been saying and now Strikers he's so
much bigger than me really well he's a
lot taller than me I would say he's 5'10
how old is he has he just turned 16. oh
he's got ways to go yeah he's gonna go
even but like even his Jujitsu is so
sharp and when we first started rolling
out I manhandled him I let him have it
you know and uh but you know every day
he's getting better he can beat you and
and well now he chokes me out you know
whoa and I'm like really I have to go
like a hundred percent now wow like 80
like now I got it I gotta go that's
pretty cool huh you could develop like
that it is it's really cool but you know
it's cooler to see them have such
respect for themselves and other people
that they would never misuse that
so when CPS came what was it like was it
shocking when they showed up did you
know they were showing up how many
people showed up it was one lady
um they had been trying to get in touch
with us and
um I really don't mess around I'm I'm
great at focusing at what I need to
focus on yeah so immediately we we got
like a letter or a phone call or
something like that and I immediately
just gave it to our attorney and our
attorney said yeah smart hey get used to
it this is going to happen now you're in
the public eye get used to it let's
develop a protocol we got this system
here's what we're gonna do you're gonna
welcome them in here's how we're going
to do this thing okay and and share
everything because you have absolutely
nothing to hide yeah so they came in and
they interviewed us all together and
then they interviewed us individually
and and so they asked them these
questions you know if your parents make
you eat testicles yeah right because the
accusations were of that sort your
parents forced you to eat testicles
forced you to drink blood force you to
get in 34 degree temperature water for
this long and force you to work out and
do these things so they interviewed
everybody asked these things and for me
my wife was actually a little bit stop
she's like you call this
child abuse yeah do you understand when
you feed your kids at this fast food I
need to call child abuse when you let
your kids play video games all day long
and to date themselves and not have this
kind of interaction sure that's
interesting she was mad and I'm like
listen like we don't need to be mad but
it's just a little bit scary or anxious
knowing that this person has the power
to remove the children from your family
I mean that's crazy right you know what
I don't know would you say you were
worried at all
I mean it's scary you were upset she
said she was upset but here's the thing
like I I had zero
ounce of concern whatsoever yeah because
because of the love that we have yeah
and because once you start to enter and
once you come over and here's the thing
the interviewer almost she knew after
about two seconds this whole thing was a
joke was a [ __ ] and she even said she's
like I I still got to do my job yeah I
still got to do this thing yeah I get it
and and at the end of the day this is
what I know the person that actually
reported us to CPS they're well
intentioned they actually really think
that we're creating harm you know and
this is the world that we live in right
and so the way I see it is this person
actually probably needs the most help
and so there's no resistance to that
there's no herder hate or pushback or
revenge or anything like that you know I
figure like we got to point our energy a
productive thing okay but not for a
second did I think oh you're gonna take
my kids from me wow you know it's scary
though just but uh yeah I'm sorry you
guys went through that but you know that
I have no clue that was the that was the
penis
it is literally this yeah no it's
sucking in and out that penis is
breathing liver
get so much coffee I just I gotta pee
again I'll be back yes so um we sell
prostate you need I'm gonna send you a
bottle of ancestral supplements prostate
so is there any other kind of unexpected
consequence of your of your newfound
fame or I don't know how Newfound it is
but I think in the recent past year
you've really exploded has there been
any other unforeseen consequences it has
been um it's been uh exciting as hell
it's been an adventure
um as you know it was about a year ago
when
um you guys reached out impulsive
reached out the full milk boys and Joe
it was like all of everyone yeah and out
of nowhere and we never had a social
media account no Facebook no Myspace
nothing and so one day we said hey if
we're going to take this message
mainstream this is what we got to do
we've had enough visitors come over to
say you got to put yourself on social
media I'm like why would I do that I
live a pretty good life why would I want
to do that and uh they said listen
because you don't have to change
anything this is passive income right
you just live your life it will
passively record what you do and I said
okay hey [ __ ] it we'll try it you're
really good at it though you're a
showman did you know that about yourself
you're like you're like a natural
Entertainer and showman like everything
you do is so theatrical or just like uh
you're really good on the camera you
disagree you don't know that about
yourself you know what I know is that I
never wanted to get in front of the
camera yeah again I loved the life that
I had before that and the thought of
doing what we're doing right now was
crippling I would I'd never wanted I'd
never wanted to invite any of this stuff
so for you to say hey you're a showman
I'll tell you you are when I feel really
good thank you for saying yeah no um
I'll say I've sharpened that sword and
and I hope when we do part two it'll be
like hey man this was even more valuable
you know this exchange so I'll say um
any other unintended consequences it's a
little bit tough we can't just go for a
walk sure it's wild you can't you
literally you can't I mean you're very
unique looking you don't wear a shirt
it's a problem you stick out you know
it's a problem and then and then you
know what I've recently I've started to
do because
I just want to hang out with my family
you know and so what we do so now when
we'll go uh to a fight because this is
what we want to go do we want to go to a
fight right we go to fights and then
we'll stay for all the camera guys leave
we stay for a day or two just to do
family stuff all I want to do is be with
my family and then it's hey liver King
pictures picture and then it's non-stop
unintended consequence absolutely is it
validation that this message is getting
out and then I bring the liver Boys in
and then I have the liver boys start
talking to girls right um I'm like all
of this is going to be a lesson and
we're all going to get even more value
out of this you don't want to put a pump
cover on and just go Incognito every now
and then this is what I do I put I put
on I put on this shirt this is my this
is and a hoodie it's it's a hoodie and a
shirt it probably helps a lot right it
helps a lot what's Wild is it happens is
it still happens yeah and then one or
two people start to line up and then
they start talking the other people
don't even know who it is you know
people start to line up just because
they see people taking so then I say to
them do you even know who I am yeah it
and if you have no idea and guess what
I'm just gonna be with my family today
yeah if you know that it's the liver guy
or some people say the liver God never
God yeah that's appropriate or crack it
up you know hey it's the liver King
because liver is King if you don't
remember anything else from this five
second interaction the name is liver
King because liver is King eat liver get
that in your life it'll change your life
and so we'll take a picture don't forget
this interaction we were meant and so so
I I'll Embrace that unintended
consequence that's probably the biggest
one I see yeah that's a big deal but but
this uh explosion of Fame on social
media has probably been extremely good
for your business eh I don't know
um I I have quite a few businesses and
and so um all that news is I'm gonna go
on social media to be the CEO of the
ancestral lifestyle I've I formed a new
company it's the liver King company all
we focus on is get the best message out
so the way that we measure value right
and I think that that we can agree that
the value that we create in the world is
is is people pay for value with time
money or both right and so if we can
improve our Impressions and improve
followership if we can start to figure
out that the message is getting out if
we can go out in public and people like
hey liver King liver Kings guess what
we're doing our job and so we get about
250 million impressions a month now but
on Tick Tock uh across platforms that's
a lot that's a lot of fun yeah and uh
and I don't know what you'd pay for that
if you were trying to to pay for that
with a lot Paper Planes you can't you
can't really pay for that because like
native when it's when it's happening
organically it's entirely different it's
more valuable way more valuable than
just like paying for it so so were you
were independently wealthy before the
whole supplement thing started is the
supplement a new business have you not
heard about how I made my money no I
haven't how'd you make your money you
really don't because people I want to
get the funniest thing but I want to get
the timeline right so were you when your
kids got sick were you already Wealthy
by then what were you doing at the time
I don't know if you would call it when
we met we were both pretty high Revenue
earners we were making about five six
hundred thousand dollars a year when we
met what were you guys doing my wife was
a dentist too so it's like that it goes
a long way wow yeah that's that's
incredible what were you doing uh I was
into device sales at the time okay
medical device medical device okay goes
into so you you have uh you're an MD
yes yeah whoa that's correct that's
incredible yeah after he's gonna sell
smart drink a lot of blood after he's
the restroom yeah yeah yeah
smart lady
um oh because she chose me
and that's the pound yeah um but you
know what I I hopefully we'll talk about
this later but we attract our
complimentary opposite in life right
this is what I believe and so when we
met we were pretty we we're doing pretty
well for ourselves
um and then we immediately said well
let's get into business she was working
for another dentist she goes hey I don't
want to do that no more let's start a
business so we started a business we
bought a practice and then I saw how
much we were Outsourcing we were sending
millions of dollars of Revenue by
referring people out I said we're not
doing that anymore we're going to bring
all that in the house we're sending
millions of dollars to dental Labs guess
what we're not doing that we're starting
a dental lab so when someone would come
and they needed like a gum surgery you
would refer them to a gum specialist
right when we first started until you
say well let's hire the gum specialist
everybody came in the house we had every
discipline of Dentistry in-house wow um
if somebody needed oral surgery guess
what you had to do you had to send them
out to an Imaging Center yeah so now
we're buying a a cat scan machine now
we're buying now we open up an Imaging
Center so we have this Comprehensive
Center of Dentistry the continuity of
care was was uncompromising vertical
integration it was vertically integrated
and again but but the coolest thing is
the quality of care went through the
roof I can't tell you how many times she
would send someone out to the oral
surgeon oral surgeon would send them
back to pointing the finger and nobody
can find them
it's all [ __ ] yeah yeah now it's
Under One Roof guess what accountability
is right here so at what so you are you
guys still in that business no oh you
probably saw that history what she said
and so I would say about um two or three
years after we got married
we had kids right away so so what we
figured out is our kids are sick and and
then we got our kids healthy and then
what ends up happening in this business
is she realizes guess what I'm not
really helping people I'm kind of
putting Band-Aids on things we really
need to counsel them in nutrition guess
what you go to your dentist with a
cavity or you need a crown you think you
want your dentist to tell you go eat
liver bone marrow egg yolks get some sun
yeah you're gonna think she's [ __ ]
crazy yeah probably well it's the
difference between trying to tackle the
symptoms and uh trying to fix the
underlying cause the root cause this is
this is something that I also agree with
uh people get mad at me when I say this
but like
this is why I value Physical Therapy
over pain management because in America
especially what what people are are
focused on doing as a consequence of all
the Pharma lobbying and all the money
that is like put into specific
Industries is just to engage in pain
management but if you don't actually
tackle like if you have an injury or if
you have uh some kind of hypertrophy or
some kind of like uh imbalance I'm dying
everybody's peeing if you have some kind
of imbalance that is going to is that is
that Primal I would say that's pretty
goddamn Primal yeah being in your pants
I mean I I hardly use the toilet
so we got we got eating dick eating
balls peeing in your pants those are the
Primal I mean how weird is it you go
over to that bucket over there you know
and and you go put I think it's pretty I
will admit sewage systems and and clean
water pretty [ __ ] good as far as you
like it as far as like advancements to
humanity have you ever taken a [ __ ]
outside in the woods yes and how that
make you feel [ __ ] awful awful awful
because I did a 21 day survival training
camp oh hell yeah uh and it was leave no
Trace principled so it was literally
like we didn't even have toilet paper uh
for those of you who don't know the
Canadian maple tree leaf is one of the
best for wiping your ass when you're in
the wild and you don't have toilet paper
because it's got like high surface 21
days
um we had a lot of like MRE style stuff
like we didn't hunt or anything like
that so it was it was terrible but I'll
tell you if you took out all of the
fiber you take one crispy Royal [ __ ]
I've heard you say this I wanted to ask
you about that and guess you don't need
to wipe yeah I don't know about that I'm
up a day boy I grew up in turkey and in
the on that side of the world we all
have bidets like every toilet has a
bidet in it unless it's one of those
things that the fancy hotel you guys put
me up have you seen those Japanese
toilets when you're coming close the lid
starts opening I rip it off every time
because that lid ain't ready for me tell
her she I mean she'll tell you you she
walks into the bathroom I I don't care
how they're gonna bail you guys for the
damage no you will never ever come into
my Suite I ripped the lid off I've never
had the butthole pleasures of a bidet
it's excellent I and it's time you like
butthole Pleasures good on you people
people use people use that in the other
you know people use that in other sides
of the of the planet and have been using
it for centuries I highly recommend it
that is one thing I'm if you're the
Evangelist of of if you're the
Evangelist of Libya I'm the bidet guy I
love it
all right all right but but to your
point there's something to say about
treating the root cause you you got to
treat the the symptom the acute medicine
but how [ __ ] dare you to not address
the root cause yeah no I think that's
bad that's why I believe in uh I value
Physical Therapy uh a lot more I would
say than pain management because if you
don't fix the the the imbalance or if
you don't do the proper exercises to
ensure that you have muscles that are
supposed to be there working against the
other muscles that are over developed
you're always going to keep running into
that same injury over and over again and
a lot of people instead of trying to fix
that injury will immediately go to the
pain management route and I don't like
that I think like fixing the root cause
is important so I agree with you even
though that is a much more comprehensive
and over the course of many years type
of solution yeah so making good choices
making healthy choices developing
healthy habits is something I'm totally
on board with so this is what happens in
dentistry is like from a holistic
approach he's like okay we're going to
help people holistic with nutrition and
with the treatments and we did that for
a little while then she said hey guess
what I'm done because we've outsourced
our most important job raising our kids
our kids are gone eight hours a day she
lives when it when it's dark out she
comes home when it's dark out yeah she
would actually drive home to a park to
cry so we wouldn't see her and then she
would come home we didn't see her cry
yes yeah and after doing that enough
time she goes I'm done I'm like what do
you mean what do you mean and she goes
no I'm done I'm never doing Dentistry
again I'm like you realize that we
bought this building it's like five
million dollars let me are you sure
we're done because she's like no I'm
done and you know what that does to me
like it at first I'm like you're like
I'm about to sell some way more way more
medical supplies they're about to be
sold well at this point I'm all in it
for a couple years at this point
um but but what I end up doing is I you
know I figure this out and this is why I
always say that your woman needs to know
that your man can protect you in a dark
alley and the people call me chauvinist
because they think it's about physical
strength and I'm talking about the
figurative of strength here right we
talked about the literal and figurative
implication here because guess what the
financial crisis is coming and it came
right the medical crisis these are
coming right crisis will happen in life
this is life your woman needs to know
that your man is going to fight that
you're going to claw your way through
any problem that you find yourself in
and so this is what it does to me like
this is another rite of passage I got to
figure this out and so I figured it out
right and and so I want you guys to know
how I really made my money and so I hold
14 patents on a fitness device and I and
I still collect royalties to this day
surprisingly what's the fitness device
have you guys heard of The Shake Weight
I'm so glad you know what this is this
is all completely made up I didn't um
those shit's made up anything else
I knew it I was like I don't see you
using any shake weight but here's the
thing you guys okay just for the record
you said you wanted me to come on and
say I was a CPA and that's how I made my
money so I'm like how do I compete where
is that I don't say that oh pull that
[ __ ] up then you said hey wouldn't it be
really funny if he come up came on and
we found out he made his money he's like
a [ __ ] CPA or something that probably
was me I said yeah of course it was a
joke but I laughed so hard and I said
how do I compete with that oh here's
what the shake weight yeah no that was
good everything I said prior to that 100
is on point
um and so what I end up doing is have
you ever used the shake weight oh I love
it we have one here oh no you don't
really wait so hold on you guys so how
much
no is liver kid does it have copyright
liver King on it here let's see Liberty
really I've never used a shake okay you
can use it
I wonder how many Segways we're gonna
sell from this episode what is it like
you just jack it off baby is it like
forearms I mean I guess it like works
here let's see you work that thing liver
listen we've already we've already sold
that we better get some royalties from
the shade wait now yeah so but you guys
had were you were hugely invested in
this dental practice how many employees
did you guys have 30. you got 30
employees and these are high these are
doctors Specialists so that's a huge
bill yeah so now it's time to sell it's
time to really mitigate the damage you
sold the business yeah it would probably
about broke even but when I said we
broke even
um at the end of it we still walked away
with the Six Million Dollar building
right which we still own today which we
still rent out oh okay interesting and
that and that's great so we knew that we
would be okay forever just on that but
remember landlord commercial real estate
um but but the big thing there was like
okay um I started writing a book and the
book sort of parlayed into the First
Nutrition supplement and I wrote a
thesis on chemical compositions in the
biochemical processes of human nutrition
it's like okay I know something about
this and and then it's special lies in
the sport supplements so it didn't make
maybe a little sense that maybe I would
get into supplements and so I figured
out okay here's How We rescued our kids
and then here's how we really got them
to thrive by taking off the sunblock by
taking out the shirts by taking off the
shoes connecting to the Earth right
comfort's not good for the organism
creating this resistance in their lives
where we can develop these adaptations
of strength where we can express more
right putting down the phone talking
about these things bonding with each
other like okay when you figure out that
this is how you can get your kids
healthy you understand this is your
obligation in life what kind of piece of
[ __ ] would I be if I didn't share this
message with the world of course sure so
I started writing this book on that and
I said you know what I'm going to do to
get more tractions I'm going to start a
company that sells these nine ancestral
tenants and you come to my company with
high blood pressure how much you want
about my product expert is going to tell
you what you need to do is take off your
shirt get some midday Sun take off your
shoes connect with the Earth these are
evidence-based ways to lower your blood
pressure and they're thinking the
customer's thinking what are you going
to sell me on what am I going to buy if
you unequivocally take care of people
and they see the benefit from it they're
a customer for life but so it seems that
you guys are pretty comfortable I mean
you're [ __ ] a private jet or it was
us or you or somebody what are you
joking or service I'm I'm dead serious
uh and then but obviously you you guys
are going to wait for that no we paid
yeah we paid for it okay yeah it's like
oh my God because that's why I said it
wasn't three in the in the video because
some because somebody sent it and
actually there's this other really big
podcast that we're doing and I thought
it was them who paid for it all and I
was like you know they don't have money
like we do owl's gonna be such an
[ __ ] yeah if I got that wrong but
here's the deal we we so the financial
standpoint you made your big bucks from
these guys here
the financial transaction the value
happens with these nine ancestral
tenants right the financial transaction
takes place when you buy the supplements
from ancestral supplements or from heart
and soil or from the fittest.com so how
did you start your find uh clients
because you can't you're a dentist no
but you weren't liver King at the time
so how did you start selling this stuff
people pay for Value right but how do
you find the people that can't be that's
got to be a hard part of starting a
business I think you went viral first
and then you started oh no no no no yeah
you're completely incorrected we started
this in 2016. so in 2016 we started this
by 2017 we did 7 million just with one
company wow how do you find the people
yeah how did people find out about liver
King
how did they find it I'm telling you I I
made a website it was called
ancestralsupplements.com I did it myself
ground up I did it like in the kitchen
yeah you know and then it resin people
would start searching articles how do I
fix my high blood pressure they read the
article oh you take off your shoes you
get sun so were you were you guys doing
like SEO PVC were you buying ads I'm
talking about all this fancy [ __ ] you
know at the end of the day when you
provide real empirical value people pay
for that [ __ ] you can call it so you're
saying it was if you build it they will
come situation that's right that's right
and so we doubled in revenue and we
doubled in revenue and now we're doing
100 million dollars a year across wow
three companies and we're just getting
Christ this is a lot of money yeah no
wonder y'all damn okay plays a little
bit better than Dentistry doesn't it
yeah but but again at the end of the day
what's happening is you hear peop we
talked about this from the beginning
people really are hurting people a lot
of people hate the lives that they're
living in people are suffering with such
desperate chronic conditions they know
they're meant for more they don't know
how to achieve more I got this really
simple elegant solution I call it
ancestral living right you can start
doing these things today and it will
change your life tomorrow and most of it
costs nothing
so this is what we're championing in the
world we just went on social media a
year ago and how is that impacted by
Scott have been huge on your businesses
be come out to be real I don't know what
I I really I don't know when you see you
making 100 million this year but you how
much were you making before you went
borrow so so we we grow by about 30 to
40 percent every company Grows by about
that percent every year we're still on
track to do that no no better no worse
and and you know how much promotion and
plugging we do we we today we had some
fun I'm so glad we talked about
ancestral supplements because you know
what's happening is we've gone so deep
in the red with liver King that my CFO
we have a centralized CFO he goes hey
man maybe you think about paying for one
of your trips ah yeah there you go from
one of your trips and I've always said
you know what if it doesn't make sense
I'm not talking about it right but if
we're eating liver and bone marrow and
testicle and and I believe in my heart
of hearts and I know this to be true you
got to get this stuff into your diet if
you're not going to do this this is a
great alternative it seems like high
quality stuff you know New Zealand
grass-fed liver there it is Boom the
highest quality yeah
um
I want to ask you a few questions and
I've got some games I want us to play do
you have a heart out or you got you're
all here for us it's up to John's
managing my schedule so John what's the
schedule
what's that song yeah I mean I'll
deliver it yeah
you guys are good till how long
you only have 15 minutes wait that that
is a heart out man
no I know but I I don't worry about him
watch your heart out I'll stay okay
you're good good
15 minutes I need way more time with
liver than that
um so do you own a shirt
I own shirts you don't own shirts right
now it's my costume but here's the thing
I don't go to stores if the hotel says
put on a shirt I don't [ __ ] go to the
hotel right
that arrives the day before right
they've discussed all this if liver King
needs to put a shirt on guess what he's
not putting his shirt on we're not
staying here wow that's commitment so
you do not wear a shirt straight up
period
I want to be as accurate as I can about
this if I'm going out in public I want
to spend time with my family I put on a
shirt I put on put on the hoodie for
Incognito uh otherwise I'm not wearing a
shirt even if it's in the in the dead of
winter you're going to see me in New
York you're going to see me all over the
place does cold affect you of course it
affects me but that's what I love it it
hurts like crazy again comfort's not
good for the organism and then you know
how when the last time you were so
goddamn [ __ ] cold that hurt you to
the Bone and then you knew what it felt
to really be warm was there ever a
moment where you're like I got to put on
a jacket answer my question first yeah I
mean yeah and some I used to live in New
York for a year yeah it gets really cold
there and do you remember how good it
felt to warm up yeah it's great and the
same thing goes with Hunger when's the
last time you were so hot
to receive that nourishment which
provides that same feeling of War right
and so do I ever put on a jacket there
are times I put on a job okay
interesting and and this is when I mean
I I fasted for sure I I get what you're
saying about that it's an incredible
feeling and the Gratitude and the way it
changes you biochemically
physiologically you know into the future
it's like
um there's so much incredible value so
once I'm starting to become hypothermic
listen I'm not going to die to prove a
point yeah okay I see so you believe in
jackets yeah but but like when do I need
a jacket in the United States I don't
know well you live in Texas right so
it's pretty warm yeah we go to New York
in the winter time you won't ever see me
wearing a jacket right I mean if I'm in
Mongolia or the Arctic and it's 10 below
we're gonna wear a jacket you're gonna
see me without a jacket and they're
going to see me with a jacket how many
shirts do you own I have hunting shirts
uh okay I probably have about a dozen a
dozen shirts and that's not a lot
they're already packed well you know
what I what I actually have uh you you
should see my closet [ __ ] why haven't
y'all posted the closet video get on it
guys you're [ __ ] slacking you're
going to my closet you'll see no shirts
hanging up no shirts whatsoever you're
gonna see about 100 pairs of shorts the
show I love that red shirts
I love that what's your brand green
shorts liver King oh you have your own
shorts brand oh my god well I don't sell
them I don't sell them we just had them
made because I wanted 100 can I take a
look at you
material yeah because I'm a fan of yeah
liver King right here you got the liver
King logo is that fleece no bro it's
just 100 cotton oh wow those look nice
thank you you should sell those
um
okay well somebody but uh but that but
that's the deal so we I own a couple of
shirts um I just you know I I don't like
to wear the shirt because I didn't wear
the shirt before social
let me ask you a question
um do you ever get embarrassed walking
with him shirtless
never yeah she's a good one she you guys
are meant to be together you think so
because I would have expected to say not
only never but I'm so goddamn proud of
the value that he expresses in the world
and then I'm his complimentary opposite
why did you not say any of that she said
I love her that's good what about the
kids I mean the kids have got to be like
dad put on a shirt probably a little bit
maybe I mean I I don't know right
um I I think sometimes
you know like I go to Burger King and I
pick a fight with Burger King you know
and I'm having a blast I'm like hey the
liver King is here you can kind of look
like the Burger King guy right wait wait
what the the hold on hold on wait he's
right headed all that [ __ ] out I'm sorry
but he's running up pull them up yeah
you're the only
people say is the crown I gotta say
there's there yeah yeah oh maybe the
beard
what if he's the same guy
I think they need to pay your ass
royalties well Burger King is terrible
though I hate the Whopper so if I go in
there picking a fight with Burger King
to prove a point
um I think they're a little embarrassed
but they also have fun they're like
Dad's doing it again
when I was their age there ain't no way
I would do anything like that you know I
mean I was such an introvert and I
didn't really connect with the outside
world and I had a tough upbringing at
that time would you say sales opened you
up a lot because it forces you to be
more extroverted you know what opened me
up a whole lot was around 15. I found a
group of guys that took me in and those
guys that took me in I call them the OG
crew I'm infinitely grateful friends
with them still oh I love them oh wow
yeah yeah we just had to get together at
liver King Ranch and and what ended up
happening it was like hey let's go talk
to those girls right and that's what
your peer group does we go talk to those
girls and we realize okay as a group
that was intimidating so from now on
it's one at a time one guy is going to
go up to three or four girls and we
would just rotate and we would rotate
and we would get so many reps in I would
say that that's when I started to kind
of Forge this at first it was her
terrific right and then with enough
failures and enough reps you start to
sharpen that skill and you learn you're
not a complete idiot I've described
overcoming social anxiety in identical
terms it is like a muscle you're right I
love that so now I'm at the gas station
my wife probably hated me at first when
we met because at the gas station in the
awkward anywhere we went she called me
diarrhea mouth
I didn't know when to stop on the
elevator on the Gondola it's like a
Tawas program this is what we did again
like what I had come from and this was
like my workout so I would say that that
probably helped me a lot does he have a
pet peeve is there something about him
or you're like just tone it down a
little bit liver King
no I I I would say I might be vulgar in
front of my kids and their friends I see
right she's at first she would be like
hey maybe you cussed too much in front
of like you're calling his friend their
friend's a [ __ ]
and let me tell you the life no Jesus
for you [ __ ] and then here's what the
kid does the kid goes but I'm not a
[ __ ] right and I'm like oh this is
where you [ __ ] up right just go with
it right because when somebody makes fun
of you here's what you better do you
better have the best comeback in the
world which you don't you're six
and so what you need to do what you need
to do is it's not going to turn around
and be like I [ __ ] your mom you know
exactly hey so so go with it go with it
like you know one of the guys had acne
all over the face right and I'm like hey
you know people are going to make fun of
you for being a pizza face right and he
goes oh you said that to him it goes out
that was unnecessary he goes I'm not a p
and I said guess what people are going
to do this and I'm gonna give you a
lesson right now because we're doing it
out of love right now we're getting into
reps I'm calling everybody every name
under the Sun get thick skin we're gonna
get the practice right now because if
you guys don't have this locker room
talk guess what in the world you're
going to compete you're trying to pick
up this girl this other guy's calling
you pizza face and guess what now you're
gonna say oh no hey I'm not pizza face
have you ever had a parent complain to
you
I think maybe they might complain to the
liver Queen they don't like to complain
any parent never be like yo can you turn
it down around the kids
or any any other parents have children
no well there you are you're all good I
want to say um like you got a call last
week I think people want to make sure
all my guns are locked up
you know the oh yeah that's normal yeah
yeah
um we we do a lot of like what about the
spears do you lock them up too the
machetes and whatnot no but I did tell
the kids I lightened up all the kids and
I said anybody who will let me take a
machete to the forehead and draw blood
you get 100 bucks okay we need to call
CPS so we do a lot of fun stuff like
that and then the kids go home with a
lot of money the kids go home with like
500 bucks and they do draw blood well I
wanted to see who was brave enough to do
it am I gonna put a machete to their
head and I said hey guys here's how
we're gonna do it I'm gonna put the
machete right there right between the
eyes boom just like that and then I'm
gonna go like that and whatever happens
as long as it draws blood you get 100
bucks and of course I'm thinking oh
everyone's gonna be skin out of their
mind
I don't know if it was Paul or Evan
Castillo but one of them stepped up and
one of them goes I'll do it
and so I I took it was actually a
massive buoy knife Bowie knife I don't
know how you say it I put it right on
his head he stayed firm I said make sure
you brace yourself I did the whole thing
the kid didn't move I said okay you get
100 [ __ ] people you didn't do it you
just I didn't do it yeah of course I
didn't do it that's crazy okay they are
not coming back the parents if they see
this they're gonna be like uh Evan
you're not going to that oh but they all
come back and they all collect money and
they all learned like the life lessons
that we go through you know and and of
course like here's the thing like you
know to be able to go through the
simulation in a safe place but not
really know how safe you are you know
like I'll put the kids in the pool in
the middle of winter and I'll say anyone
who can stay in the pool for five
minutes you get 200 bucks right so
everybody jumps in the pool and now now
I really start to [ __ ] with them and now
after about two minutes it's cold right
and that's I say it's cold but it's like
50 maybe maybe 60.
um and I said now it's been two minutes
right if you get out right now I'm gonna
give you your money but if you can get
in the cold plunge where it's 34 degrees
massively different right and they're
already cold I said if you get in the
cold plunge I'll double it and so here's
the thing anyone we're doing part-time
work at your house doing stunts well
I'll tell you what what it is here's the
thing um one chose to do it nobody else
did and the longer you thought about it
the colder you were getting anyways what
you needed to do is you need to act
immediately and so here's the lesson
right regret the things that you do not
the things you don't do the knee-jerk
reaction is okay I'll do it okay I'll do
it because guess what you're gonna
you're gonna regret for the rest of your
life that you didn't reach for her hand
because somebody else you didn't you you
declined to do the shake with
McDonald's about going to eat McDonald's
if you hand me McDonald's no right
anything that's so damn clearly subprime
I think you need to prove to us that
your body is optimized to handle that
Poison by eating up to you oh I thought
it's all about proving that you're well
I guess you don't have to prove anything
to me but I like how you cut yourself I
like that oh prove it to myself Yeah
well yeah that's what you're testing
your body okay I mean you're testing
your body right you're trending your
body let's get a Big Mac in there
oh put a Big Mac see if I can handle the
poison yeah do you know how long that
linoleic acid stays into your cell
that's our seed oil I was about to say I
feel like he would die if he had like
like normal food once after you've
trained your body for years but I it's
kind of like uh if you're always eating
at home if you always cook your own
meals and then you go out and eat like
you'll you'll feel so dried up from the
amount of sodium that they put in like
regular processed Meats it also coats
the roof of your mouth there's there's
something different about it you know
and and I know what it does to you
biochemically I just I I'll push back
from that so I want to go back so
basically
um Ethan is saying he's more Primal for
being able to take down frozen pizzas
yeah my body's my body is unbeatable
yeah I eat that [ __ ] all day prove it
let me see the six pack prove it
so
um you said you had a hard upbringing
what does that mean what was it like
your relationship with your parents yeah
well I didn't have a dad growing up uh
he died before I knew him I don't want
to tell this whole sob story because
I've told it a couple of times but uh
basically from about 10 to 15 I just got
the [ __ ] handed to me every day at
school I was the only one of my kind oh
[ __ ] yeah oh my God I mean I just get
clocked out or walked out what would
they bully you about most of the time I
didn't even know but but this is really
clear I was the only one of my kind I
was the only white kid there I was Tiny
I was an easy target you know and I
would just get punched I'd get knocked
out the Bell would ring I'd wake up I'd
collect my books and I'd go to class and
actually the first day of school this
happened the very first day Felix
[ __ ] Sanchez I hope you're watching
Felix Sanchez from San Antonio from Pat
Neff you grew up in Texas I did in San
Antonio uh what we kind of migrated from
Air Force base to Air Force Base uh
because my dad was in the military
um but but here's what and then I was
probably two or three when he died was
it was it related to the military Terry
his death uh it's complicated actually I
don't want to get into that okay sure so
what ends up happening is uh you know
this is just my middle school I remember
coming home saying Hey listen I'm never
going back I think a lot of people
probably said that hey I'm never going
back but my mom didn't let me she was
like Hey listen I'm not even listening
to this this is not even an option and
from then on I knew I could never tell
her another story about what happened
and so I just took it like every day I
took it and I remember coming home just
no self-worth humiliated of this guy I
would see in the mirror I mean we I told
you these horrific statistics about
suicide there's no [ __ ] way that that
I I this this is a real thing that I had
contemplated like why why would I exist
in a world like this this was such a
horrific world and all I wanted to do
was be like them I said this yesterday
on a podcast like I didn't want to be in
this body or look like this or have this
color skin all I wanted to do was be
like these guys that were kicking
everybody else's ass I just wanted to be
like these guys so that's what it was
for like four or five years you know
just no self-worth nothing but I was I
was working out at this time and then
I'll never I'll never forget I was
probably about 14 or so and uh I was
playing basketball in the court and
somebody said hey you look like Marky
Mark
and I lost it I lost it I'm like holy
[ __ ] like Marky Mark is like a stud and
and then I started to realize about that
time I'm like hey you know what I I kind
of do look like Marky Mark I'm gonna
start taking my shirt off and then other
other guys started giving me compliments
and other girls for the first time ever
started looking at me interesting I
changed my whole life they were Myron
you you started your exercising Journey
around like Hey Hey My My mom's
boyfriend gave gave me a bench he was a
pharmacist I started using it um eight
years old I was eight or nine yeah by
the way I have a picture of young liver
King yeah that's young liver King at 15.
I mean look look at this you ever seen a
15 year old built like that
where your arms don't even go down I
think I was probably trying to make
myself look bigger but yeah I mean I I
looked okay I wish somebody told me to
do some more squats back then you mean
you looked okay you got you got good
definition even in your quads for 15.
thank you thank you that's crazy yeah
that is that but because this is the
time when people were giving me those
compliments and and that changed my life
you know that's when I figured out like
I I actually figured out my way out of
this hellhole without a dad without a
mentor with anybody to tell me what to
do Fitness was your basically salvation
from everything oh yeah I would agree to
that I I had a similar experience as
well I'm both being bullied and
everything I was always fat so once I
was able to I don't know we were fat
like I know you were big oh wow it was
really fat yeah I I always wanted to not
be fat I always wanted to have like
these goals like I wanted to be able to
dunk and I wanted to have a six-pack
yeah it was like a silly [ __ ] but
um but when I was able to actually
accomplish it and I talk about this all
the time it gave me the confidence to be
able to do whatever ever I want because
I knew like well this was my main goal
my entire life and I was able to achieve
that so now yeah as long as I put my
mind to it and as long as I you know put
enough effort into it I know I can
accomplish whatever I want if you don't
mind I want to really put that into
liver King words because I like to talk
about this because there's you know how
many kids are going through what we both
went through right I mean I get these
DMS every single day I hate my life
liver King where do I start and I say
start eating liver and and start lifting
heavy [ __ ] learn the Barbarian train the
Barbarian become a barbarian you guys
know about this workout because here's
what ends up happening is you become
physically strong but physical strength
doesn't mean [ __ ] it's about the process
that got you there when you realize that
this active suffering this is
self-imposed active suffering active
struggling this Relentless effort every
day enables you to do something that you
otherwise thought was possible it's that
process that you realize I can point
that process at anything in life and I
can achieve the highest level of success
success in all my roles and goals that's
why I'm always trying to get him to go
to the gym I started exercising but I
don't I don't like lifting weights you
know he says he doesn't feel good after
he works out I don't know I do I change
my routine and now I do oh okay good
because like I I've never there's never
been a moment in my life where I went
and I worked out and I suffered through
that and then I felt worse afterwards
every time I go and I and I punish
myself in the gym no matter how shitty I
feel no matter how shitty the weather
conditions are because we're working
outside yeah uh at the moment that I'm
done with that workout I feel a sense of
accomplishment across the board and also
you know all the hormones when you have
self-imposed resistance like that we're
we're wired to have that reward system
yeah right we're wired for that this
morning I thought about this because I
thought you know I want to be sharp for
this is you guys paid all this money for
me to be here you know and I wanted
there to be reciprocal value and I
thought holy [ __ ] like what if I think
today I thought you know I'm not gonna
do my workout this morning I laid there
in bed for a minute thinking I'm gonna
skip my workout because I want to be my
best because I have really heavy
deadlifts this morning and that will tax
your scene us and then you're bumbling
[ __ ] where are you working out maybe
you're working out I got this incredible
uh machine called the Vitruvian there's
no professional relationship but this
vertruvian you could do five six hundred
pound deadlifts you could do 600 pound
squats on it if you watch my score with
that um we yeah we travel with goodness
yeah and that's a nice thing when you
send me the big jet boom yeah absolutely
how heavy is it it's 100 it's only 100
pounds but it has these motors it has
this technology this is an amazing again
if you just watch my story today you're
gonna see some really heavy deadlifts
and squats on there that's that's the
machine so but but here's the thing I
thought about that I'm like do I want to
tax my CNS and I thought I have to
because this is what I do and I might
not be a 10 today on the podcast but if
I'm at eight and a half eleven thank you
for saying that yeah yeah I know this is
great this is my favorite leftovers
episode so far but but again you you
always feel great
I like that but to your point like you
you swallow I spit yeah
those are quitters man you guys are
[ __ ] crazy
I was on a podcast yesterday with all
this like similar talking I'm like I
don't I don't even know what to say
about any of that stuff but but when you
come with a big old [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
and start feeding people you got to
expect something dirty yeah yeah I gotta
get this on yourself you're right
self-imposed yeah but but you're right
like you you don't get through a workout
say oh now I feel like [ __ ] right about
myself or physically so I'm glad that
you're you're figuring some of that
stuff out but how much you want to bet
like we're gonna take this one step at a
time we're gonna start with liver and
bone marrow we're gonna stay in touch
we're going to get some sun in there
absolutely and and we're just gonna
incrementally ratchet that that thing up
when did you start being no shirt
maybe a debt maybe 10 years I don't know
if 10 years ago anywhere from 8 to 12
yeah
oh you were no no no no no no no 12
years ago oh I was like
he's not selling CPAP machine shirtless
like you know whatever but you know um
so do you often go in stores and they
ask you to leave and that's just part of
your life
I I try to I'll get that asked that
question a lot I really don't go to
stores I mean at Liberty shop for you
well like what do you need again I don't
wear clothes yeah okay right I mean I
mean he doesn't really eat anything that
you're you know all of my food comes
from liver King Ranch or white oak
pastures what will help with that uh
it's like I mean I'm so satiated from a
social emotional physical like what I
have everything you need so you don't
have any clothes he's not buying clothes
where is he going what what is the last
time that's what I'm trying to think I'm
trying to think the last time I went to
the store was actually
um have you guys do you have Kroger out
here yeah I went there to make a video
but I don't I don't grocery shop in fact
my my social media teams are they're
like hey let's go do a video of you
grocery shopping I'm like I haven't
grocery shopping over a decade in 15
years I'm not going to go pretend that I
do something because they had this great
idea I'm like I am who I am passive
income is what I call social record my
life as I live it catch up stay up with
me right and so
um I reached recently went to a Kroger
to do a video with I don't know if you
guys have heard of the carnivore MD his
name is Paul Saladin yeah I know him the
guy is just an encyclopedia and so we
went and we did something in there but
but that was just for filming so if
you're asking me like when did I go to
they ask you to leave or they didn't
care you know what this happens all the
time okay you guys are gonna love this
um
so we were at a Chick-fil-A mm-hmm
getting filming like hey here's how you
can order Primal sandwiches by the way I
eat Chick-fil-A all the [ __ ] time
there's grilled chicken sandwiches you
know there's there's certainly you can
eat Primal there yeah you can get you
can get I mean not Primal like it's not
raw but yeah but you know it doesn't
have to be subprime grilled chicken
nuggets there's grilled chicken tenders
so the grilled chicken is a primal meal
so grilled chicken but listen what I
tell everybody Hey listen here's how you
order Primal and I'm gonna give you 100
bucks to order Primal for the next week
lose the Buns double double the chicken
right and listen if you really want to
have those buns because a lot of people
do what you got to do is 30 push-ups
before you eat that's all you got to do
right so there's a primal way to eat and
a subprime away to eat and mitigate most
of that damage it's incredible what a
glycogen sink we are if we do just a
little bit just a little bit of exercise
we would have never just Fallen across
oh my God look at all these calories we
always work for some calories they call
the cops on us right hey you better
leave you better leave we're calling the
cops Chick-fil-A called the police yeah
but this this happens a lot so they'll
call the cops and uh and you know what
you get the most views when the cops
come so like we're we're in the UK
recently and I'm trying to get you think
it was it was it because it was a bunch
of shirtless dudes like what happened
yeah I mean I'm gonna tell you I'm going
to tell you um it's so uh none of that
gay stuff no shirtless men here that's
true
they feel like we're causing a commotion
because yeah everyone's coming up to us
wanting to take pictures no one's
ordering food you know and I guess for
the couple of core customers that are
there to eat it's a spectacle okay and
so what ends up happening the sheriff
shows up and so uh again I'm thinking oh
this could be like you know a conflict
and uh she goes oh hey it's liver King
Ah that's good can I get a picture with
you wow and I'm like absolutely let's
take a picture I mean I can't start a
fight with her now and the same thing
happens with with the Queen's guard we
went way before she passed away just for
the record because some stupid [ __ ]
showed up on social media liver King was
not there when the queen died let's let
them suspect right no this is here's
what some people said on social media
not go to Aberdeen in Scotland they said
that we try to go and and do some
marketing Ploy off of right you were
there before we were there a month or
two ahead of time and so I'm going up to
the guards and I'm saying the king is
here let me in and I got dumbbells and
I'm curling and uh and I'm hoping
because I know they're pretty serious
I'm thinking oh this is we're gonna get
views
um they start laughing and they're like
we know who you are like holy [ __ ] like
they're famous it's not working so um in
terms of really going to a store they
didn't know who I was I'll tell you that
much when I was asking if the queen is
actually dead way before I went a couple
months before as well they were not
happy they weren't interested no the
British people were not happy with me
being like the queen might be dead
actually do you think she's maybe
Clairvoyant though yeah well what's Wild
a lot of the guards ended up wanting
pictures I loved it I mean it is great
Queen can you think of the last time
that we legitimately went into a store
I'll tell you I I am watch shopping
right now and so okay yeah watch shops
what do you got right now what do you
got on I got a 20 that's what I'm saying
so you're gonna go with that right or so
this is why I watch something because I
I won't watch I want to watch to give to
my kids and and I'm like okay I'm gonna
have that right now and uh and you know
what I want a really cool watch also
because we're going to Dubai and I'm
like you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
wear this cool watch and and so what
ends up happening is like the watch guy
comes to our house and he opens up his
bag and has a couple of watches so the
thing is I I know when I point myself at
something the value that I can create
and I can get out of it the minute you
put me in a car the minute you put me
somewhere else it's not worth it to me
right so I will gladly pay a lawyer or a
watch guy or anybody to come to me right
so that I can focus on what I need to
focus on to create expensive watch
shopping you know and really go to
stores for that anyway I don't think I
have I have a I have questions well I
mean yeah I don't know I don't have any
expenses let me ask you this I
understand that you don't wipe your ass
is that true most of the time that's
true yeah
so that I find that really interesting
your shits are just really like clean
they're clean they're crispy crispy you
know and and you and you know listen
slightly fried are you supplementing
with fiber though you're not just eating
some of it with fiber no this man this
liver King you just straight you shits
meat wait what are you wrong every once
in a while we'll have some guacamole
right this is not part of my daily
routine every once in a while we'll have
some fruit this is every once in a while
like I I don't have a lot of fruit you
don't want to go crazy now with the
fruit well here's the thing like we have
an orchard at liver King Ranch if a
peach is growing I'll grab it right I'm
not going out of my way to grow stuff or
or I'm sorry to order stuff that isn't
local or actually in season so what do
your shits look like they're just
perfect man I mean just a nice log have
you ever taken a bottle of a nice one
where you're like this is the queen well
send it to her I should just leave it in
there as a trophy yeah you could do that
too
um but but here's the thing I mean when
you do it every day you know you know
what a perfect one feels like you don't
even like you don't
you don't use soap right so like you
could have [ __ ] in your ass right now so
everyone that's what I'm like everyone
so if it doesn't feel the way that I
know it's supposed to feel yeah like you
know what I'm gonna check I'm gonna
check okay so so you have you can sense
when the [ __ ] was a little messy yeah
and then you'll go in with the toilet
paper do you have a bidet no I'll go in
with a toilet paper yeah dude you gotta
try the bidet I promise
It's Gonna Change
that's the Primal bro yeah no but days
are excellent I have a bidet that dries
my ass
yeah I I got one recently put in by wow
oh from the beginning yeah I I got one
as well I I don't you don't need all
that stuff all you need is like all you
need is like a regular one you know what
I mean just
spray some water in there okay what
other questions no wait hold on I'm not
done with this so so you [ __ ] and then
uh you said you have diarrhea sometimes
uh I've had diarrhea before it's like
hardly ever you know like when we went
to Africa holy you got you guys was it
from the water I don't know what it was
from probably but like after a couple of
days it's like black water oh yeah and
then so you're useless in the water
you're using white you're wiping up in
that situation well oh my God yeah you
listen you don't even wipe in that
situation you're getting this just move
on yeah I guess the equivalent of the
bidet yeah yeah what's wiping gonna do
and so you don't use soap right well you
get you do take showers but just to
rinse off yeah we use well water we get
in the lake we do a cold plunge uh every
once in a while like so we have a bar of
Tallow right and that's like the
original soap is Tallow right animal fat
just fat it's just fat and that actually
lathers up a little bit I would never
use that to so everybody knows about the
gut microbiome right everybody I mean
seriously like you know it's a really
important yeah yeah yeah and did you
know that we also have an oral
microbiome yes and we also have a skin
microbiome and every time that you use
some sort of destructive detergent you
disrupt that skin microbiome now I'm not
saying that my skin looks better than
yours but what I understand is beautiful
surprisingly
um but but here's the thing um because
you're saying he's on steroids no
because he's [ __ ] Under the Sun
non-stop well he's got a nice little the
queen too yeah on your skin
facial practice if they're not so you
use facial creams and stuff
okay
but she doesn't yourself on her body
either to disrupt that skin microbiome
okay and then let me ask you this do you
shave your pubes why the [ __ ] would you
do that I'm just curious
you're going to shave your pubes some
people a lot of people groom they want
to look good down there how new is that
you know it's like people have that's
that's old that's been around do you
think people did that in the 20s
I don't know about that that's what I'm
saying like the modern day manicured man
is starting to do certain things today
that look that make them look less like
their Primal wild first version self
yeah but I'm fine I think the ladies
like a little I'm not talking about the
queen I mean you guys have their your
own things I think the ladies like some
trimming well are you in a relationship
no because for you it doesn't [ __ ]
matter no but but here's the deal so so
you're hooking up with girls you know or
whatever every once in a while
um if all guys are manicured like that
you show up and you're not [ __ ]
manicured guess what this guy's this
guy's different I don't know if that's a
good this guy's a man this guy smells
different this guy is [ __ ] built
different this guy's different you know
this guy's the most Primal guy I've ever
been with I I look here's the thing I
don't really do too much uh now but back
in the day when I was more refactive no
no no no I trim yeah even when I'm even
when I'm not active I try to be ready I
like I like the way it uh I like the way
it looks I like the way it feels yeah
your dick looks like I um and I need all
the help I can get
um I just uh I'm a fan I'm a fan
regardless of like uh grooming I think
it's good I've never been to a permanent
culture tribe where they give a [ __ ]
about grooming okay fair enough
um and I just want to say by the way
hair serves a functional purpose right
and you just got to be thinking what are
you doing teach your own for the record
I shave no part of my body right okay I
understand you guys have to leave in 15
minutes so I'm gonna hit you with some
rapid fire stuff okay
um
um do you uh do you can uh Hassan do you
want to smell him and see what's going
on I I already did yeah everybody yeah
yeah liver King is here you got you you
definitely have some you have some BO
it's not as disruptive as I thought it
was going to be yeah but there's but you
can you can definitely I can definitely
smell you thank you and so um do you use
toothpaste no early ancestors didn't
brush didn't you didn't get cavities do
you brush I don't use toothpaste I don't
brush I don't fly you don't even deal
with the mouth and I don't get cavities
okay interesting yeah wow and and um do
you um
I think I'm going to do a disservice to
your listeners if I don't just at least
tell them this if you don't want to get
cavities get the fat soluble system
right you need Vitamin A d k and E in
other words you need to eat liver bone
marrow egg yolks get sun it's a One-Stop
shop liver is just helping everyone I
know what I want I know about this stuff
and you have to mechanically load the
teeth so if you're eating baby food if
you're eating stuff where you're not
mechanically loading that then you're
you're still going to have oral health
issues so you need to mechanically load
and you need that that kind of nutrition
you're gonna be good to go uh liver King
now do you have to have sex in a certain
position because you're so big and
sometimes fat guys have a problem they
have to they have to go into a certain
position because I mean you're massive
right so yeah so and also I don't know
how well endowed you are but like what's
the situation with your what how what
position do you have to go in a position
are you guys fully flexible because
you're both very muscular yeah
um here's the thing
um never talk about my wife in this
context oh okay
yeah I I I don't talk about my sex life
you know with the queen um in that level
of detail what I'll tell you is this is
y'all got that weird bed like that's not
oh we have wooden planks you know but
here's the thing you know you don't need
a [ __ ] bed to have sex yeah I wonder
where would you do it if not on the bed
and on the wooden planks just on the
earth anywhere and everywhere else it's
anywhere is that the only place you have
better I mean sex and if that's the
other place you have sex I feel sorry
for you but right I mean especially if
you have kids because if you have kids
you you got to be opportunistic you
gotta get it in real quick also your
kids are homeschooled so God you know
what I mean but I but I always say this
um is uh you earn the life and and wife
and sex life that you behold and we
attract our complementary opposites and
if you want to wake up next to a person
that you love and you absolutely lust
you owe it to yourself and you owe it to
her to express respectful King that was
very respectful but but this is the deal
um I I want to get this message out
because there's too many people they get
married they get comfortable and then
they're getting five pounds a year in
perpetuity and now they've been married
for 10 years and now they weigh 220
pounds each and now you're less
attracted to that person and now you're
looking outside of the marriage you're
looking outside of the relationship for
what you deem to be sexy and lustworthy
you still love the person but you don't
wake up lusting that person right and so
I feel like you owe it to yourself you
owe it to her to express your highest
and most dominant physical form and
guess what she'll do the same you pull
each other forward in that ecosystem and
that what a gift this is this is not an
incredible amount of work you have to do
every day right you commit to 30 minutes
a day a couple of days a week and you're
going to produce such a physical
specimen of yourself and you're going to
feel great guess what she's your
complimentary opposite she's going to
look the same way and imagine you get a
wake up to the person that you know is a
10 every [ __ ] day lovely yeah do you
do are you into semen retention you seem
like a guy who'd be into that why
I don't know
you like to hold it all the way how can
you say I seem like a guy and I say why
I don't know it's just a Vibe you hold
in you got to keep all the nutrients I
guess the SEMA retention thing is about
like I hold on to the masculine energies
and it's just there's a lot of bro signs
out there on Instagram
so I I do things based on the first
principle thinking and what our early
ancestors did and what modern day and
they were not doing not only is there no
semen retention right there's no
discussion of that kind of [ __ ] we don't
talk about it I don't know they didn't
talk about it you know what you can have
with yourself why I'm sure that you
think early man jerked off
are you kidding me I mean what else they
gonna do they got no time they have so
much time in the day to fill so here's
what I'm gonna do on part two when when
we do this again yeah I'm going to have
an I'm going to I I have a list of
questions I ask these tribes God forbid
I don't know what they're gonna think
about well you're gonna ask them I'm
gonna start asking to ask us questions
and I'm going to report back because
this is not I'm sure they don't do semen
retention well we went on another
podcast it was pardon my take and they
asked this question and they asked
someone asked me this already my man who
the [ __ ] Billy football oh it was Billy
Billy football but but those guys those
guys are giants man I love those guys
yeah in their respective Fields these
are great guys and so I'm like you know
what if that's the first time I've ever
heard about it and I'm thinking why why
and again now you guys are asking so now
this is something that someone is trying
to look into it let me look into it let
me actually set the record straight is
masturbation allowed in the Primal uh uh
to be Primal is masturbating Primal well
that you know to each Road here's what
I'll say about about that when you wake
up next to your [ __ ] 10 you don't
need it you wake up you're single Primal
well if you're single Primal uh listen I
can't tell you from personal experience
right you don't jerk off I I don't jerk
off because I got a [ __ ] 10 next to
me right
okay but when you were single yeah when
you were I mean
of course okay all right if you don't
jerk off
what the [ __ ] is wrong with
wrong all right hold on I I want to go
out with a loaded gun you gotta that's
that stuff listen I prepared a bunch of
uh little games I want to fit in because
I know you're in a hurry tell me can you
do you want to play Guess the vegetarian
are you willing to do that do you think
you have a when you say guess like is it
a person oh yeah it's one of the people
I'm gonna show you on the crew and you
guess who's the oh on the crew do you
think you could do that or no yeah I
could do that for sure okay here we go
so this is Cam
this is Dan
this is Ian
this is Lena everyone's crying this is
Zach that one's hard he's covered up no
that's pretty obvious
uh Olivia
love
baby
so so I guess me I'm not I'm not a
vegetarian so so do you have a guess
here
scroll again slowly yeah and I'll tell
you when to stop yeah stop
Ian 100
I love meat it's actually Dan [ __ ] Dan
you're a vegetarian what the [ __ ] I feel
betrayed the beard the beard got you
well let me make this official the nine
ancestral tenants are vegan friendly
right only one of them is eat right so
you can still do the nine ancestral tips
and be 89 Primal okay
here's another one I bet you he's doing
the other ancestral tenants oh Dan is
definitely a primal thanks man thanks
for saying something contain erotic or
adult imagery I don't know I want to
show you a uh an image of something
specific and you just tell me is it
Primal or subprime can you do that sure
okay so caveman Primal yeah
wild berries primal
uh sunscreen
bro this is embarrassing you're asking
no I couldn't keep going stop right all
the way 100 okay sparkling water plastic
is subprimal what about in glass Primal
okay uh Prime energy drink I love those
guys yeah but but so all I'm gonna say
is this is loyalty above all its name is
prime
Primal and and and the new shot that's
plastic too come on
this guy saw worth and potential in me
before I knew that I had it myself I
invited you before they did for the rest
okay but for them would you drink that
would you drink that for the record look
at how your producer reached out to me
right and how did he do it well I I read
the DM verbatim was it bad well all I'll
tell you is this um Logan Paul and Paul
said hey we'll come to you oh yeah I was
I wasn't gonna of course of course you
weren't but again you sent the jet you
put me up okay okay so that yeah okay so
that's that's definitely not would you
drink this after a workout listen I love
these
escalator oh this is easy we would never
[ __ ] touch it
take the stairs always yeah and if
there's no stairs you don't go NASA
nerds NASA is always [ __ ] Primal yeah
outer space that's Primal effects
obviously okay what about the Haley
Bieber beefing with Selena Gomez I don't
know anything about that yeah nothing
okay Queen Elizabeth
the second
[Music]
Primal Primal really you you you were
hesitating
the most so primal thing ever you got
like a you got a you got a monarch
that's like wearing all this crazy [ __ ]
you know what I mean and it's like dress
up stolen yeah stolen money and land off
of like that is Primal though no Primal
people pillaging is Primal right I lived
off the Earth this is why I called this
disclaimer earlier I I live in a primal
bubble I don't know what's trending I
don't know when the tornado is coming or
the hurricane I prospectively create the
light I don't half the [ __ ] you're
showing me I I don't even know so the
queen is Primal let's move on uh
gambling gambling is always bribble
interesting gambling's Primal 911.
here's what you gotta do
here's what you got to do because uh you
gotta take risks that are commensurate
with a reward right this is what the
evolutionary Hunter did yeah I'm talking
about gameplay
gamble chasing an animal is a gamble
exactly what's the potential reward
payoff life yeah and then are you guys
on that did you guys not hear my video
on this I did I walked yeah no I saw you
I know it's ultimate well it's it's
dedication to a belief you know they put
it was a huge act like listen you you
can call it you call it
I've already put my steak in the sand
I've said what I believe okay those
homies were living I agree I agree for
the record subprimal soy face
this is this face people make for like
YouTube thumbnails they go and what does
soy face even yeah people not us we
would never do that it's like uh uh we
can move on you know what I want to make
a point when you make a face like that I
believe that you invite attack upon
yourself okay you invite attack upon
your family I think when you emasculate
yourself like that when you do that to
yourself boom soy face sub Primal okay
what about soybeans even more subprival
you don't like soy you don't like
soybeans are you joking me right it's a
natural that's a natural okay estrogen
what about women eating soybeans uh you
probably still don't want to do a whole
I mean it's such a strong estrogen
memetic we don't like that well what
happens with there's like this
reciprocal relationship with estrogen
and testosterone right and you listen we
live in such an estrogen dominated world
not in terms of like man and woman but
in terms of when you start wearing
petrochemical clothing when you start
wearing xenoestrogens like the perfumes
and fragrances and and the deodorants
those types of things estrogen is just
stacking and compounding so no soy no
what about uh God
this is a complicated topic okay damn
the dialectic is in okay
this is just a complicated topic refuse
to answer I I believe that he's both
Primal and sub Primal if he's everything
right yeah he's everything we'll go with
that yeah technically he's so probably
how about Jesus look you know what I
think this this part is getting a little
bit funny okay we'll skip that we'll
skip that if you're not comfortable I
get it yeah it's a little bit Wi-Fi well
this is obviously yes sub Primal uh
Corporate America
uh murder
well it depends on what the cause is or
what what the reason is behind it you
know like uh murder and fighting for
your life you know has always been part
of our evidence yeah that's fair that's
a good answer what about regular
colonoscopy checks after the age of 40.
I would say that's uh you know what I
don't want to [ __ ] anybody up without
I'm not going to say [ __ ] but I I I'll
tell you off camera what that is you
don't take a finger in the butt you know
I I don't go see doctors you don't
believe it here's what you here's what
happens you go see a doctor they're
going to tell you what's wrong with you
irrespective of you being as healthy as
an ox yeah so if you don't ask you know
I have to ever know that there's
something that you can do I get it this
is a legitimate issue and people do need
to be diagnosed with this early okay and
so that's why this is such a nuanced
topic but here's the thing you live the
nine ancestral tenants you're kicking
ass in life you have great energy a
kicking ass libido you know your
prostate is gonna be the size of like
this that's what you're saying it's
pretty accurate but here's the thing
people aren't living that way people are
living subprime lives sub Primal lives
you need to get that [ __ ] done if you're
subprimal you need a finger in the butt
sure got it tucking your son in at night
oh man
um I did I took my son and uh my kids
for a while so
um
it depends their age interesting it
completely depends on the nighttime a
little nighttime story and it look
kissing a child I'd say under under 10
uh under 10 I'm good with that yeah
that's right 11 though cut that out yeah
uh Seafood oh that's cell Primal no
here's the thing is uh um I said this
yesterday landlocked tribes at War
always would call a peace treaty to
exchange at least one day out of the
week because Seafood was required uh to
express their health and happiness so
um Seafood uh fish eggs and fish have
always been and listen we don't do a lot
of it but one day a week we do some
seafood okay so no I would say it's
absolutely Primal and how about keeping
cholesterol levels below 200 milligrams
DL yeah I don't know if you know but
that's synonymous with lowering your
testosterone the prime we don't do we
don't do blood tests well we don't do
clothes I already did a blood test it's
online Google Assistant what about the
planet Mars
oh [ __ ] I don't know anything about it
we refused to answer are you giving is
it giving Vibes like is it giving
subpromal or Primal vibes
but it seems pretty goddamn Primal
Primal yeah I mean it's a planet uh what
about Mars the the Roman God of War it's
pretty shredded what else is there about
him well tell me something about him I
don't know he's a mythological God of
War it's fine what about birth control
um birth control is probably not Primal
interesting you don't see condoms not
Primal of course no you know but again
this is such a nice topic agreed with
that one condoms but you guys must be
using contraceptive you only have two
kids and it sounds like you guys [ __ ]
like rabbits the the this is something
that I'm gonna go back to what I said
earlier you know once we get into this
level we don't we don't talk about that
we don't yeah fair enough very
respectful uh what about selling feet
picks online
you know I'm I'm not really enjoying
this anymore so I'm gonna be like hey
look oh yeah okay we can call it off
yeah yeah we can call that yeah I mean I
get it if you like doing that I was just
like I I don't really enjoy that and hey
you saying you say no and we're out I
appreciate that yeah that's about that
was just a little game we prepped damn
you had some crazy stuff in there too
balls in there I don't know a bunch of
challenge in there yeah I was I thought
maybe do you like you don't eat any
spice oh we need a little bit you like
spicy food
I I like some spicy food yeah do you
know what the one chip challenge is
never heard of it so it's a it's a
tortilla chip but it's carbs you're
probably not going to be interested but
it's uh
it's spiced with like ghost pepper I
think we all we all did it on the crew
last week it's very spicy but it's fun
because it's so spicy it's like oh you
want me to do that here yeah I'm I'm
gonna pass on yeah I figured the
tortilla chip it's probably fried in
some [ __ ] vegetable oil yeah yeah
yeah you know but here's the thing I
will go on the what's it called hot ones
or something like that have y'all heard
of that show yeah I was on it Shawna oh
where are you how'd it go it was great
you went on Sean Evans show he's my
mortal enemy did you know this why why I
didn't even know it but yeah he's my
he's my mortal enemy I was on there a
long time you wanted the shorty award
over me the year I flew in with David
dobrik on the private jet oh that's not
right he won a best breakout uh show
over my show would you lick it maybe do
not eat it just no
but you guys this has been a blast you
know again I appreciate the hospitality
um just putting me up and and thank you
absolutely I want to do a part two you
know me too at some point me too let's
go check value in ourselves and that way
we come back to next time and
everything's at another level we're
gonna do the liver bone marrow so is
this mine to keep absolutely okay I'm on
it okay let's see what happens badass
and obviously we got your contact info
we're gonna make sure that you stay
supplied without okay you want you want
some you want some of this yeah okay
we're gonna make sure to get that lead
Dominator you guys here
okay can we just make sure to get a
couple of rounds to the guys
okay badass but once again I said this
in the beginning um how desperately I
need guys like you for opportunities
like this I just want to repeat this
there's too many people that are hurting
and hating their lives today they're
suffering at record rates there's a
better life to live out there if you
start living the ancestral tenants start
eating liver stack the sun in the earth
tune into the liver King message and
you're gonna live a life that's goddamn
worth living yeah thank you for this
opportunity thank you so much all right
we're wrapping it up unfortunately we
had the Barbarian test I wanted to put
you through that Hassan but uh I guess
you you guys are you guys have another
place to be right whatever John is
saying yeah yeah yeah okay which podcast
is it
uh Bradley Martin oh yeah you could you
can go late to that one
that's not a big deal do culture dude
what's that
okay yeah he said you have to you they
have to go Bradley Martin yeah so um
which camera because I at the end I
always do a liver King out I want to be
able to let that be yours yeah okay do
you mind if I do it right now go ahead
okay so uh again thank you guys and now
we're done liver King out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]